And three, two, one.
Cold open.
Hey, it's podcast time, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
You're live on podcast time.
We're cold opening.
Yeah, we're.
We're getting ready to do our little show.
三，二，一。冷开场。嘿，各位，播客时间到了。欢迎，欢迎。你们正在收听播客时间。我们正在进行冷开场。是的，我们正在准备我们的节目。
I hope you stick around for that instead of just this.
Yeah, you get ready to listen.
We'll get ready to talk.
Ready, set, go.
Welcome to Smartless.
I'm going full tilt this morning.
It's a smartless.
It's one of our OG original ones.
我希望你们留下来听节目，而不只是听这段。好的，准备好收听吧。我们准备好开聊了。预备，开始。欢迎来到《Smartless》。我今天早上火力全开。这是《Smartless》。这是我们最初的元老级节目之一。
Smartless, howdy?
You're cool dad this morning.
Did I tell you?
So the other day, I've never wanted it out of the house, obviously, for every...
Yeah, you don't want people to know that.
Well, also, it's got our faces on the back.
Yeah, you don't want to be like, hey, hey, Johnny wearing his merch.
So the other day, wearing the house, went to do my little walk that you guys know, and forgot that I had it on.
《Smartless》，你好吗？你今天早上真是个酷老爸。我跟你说了吗？前几天，我显然不想让它出现在家里……是的，你不想让别人知道。好吧，而且它的背面印着我们的脸。是的，你不想让人觉得，嘿，嘿，强尼穿着他的周边商品。所以前几天，在家里，去散步，你们都知道的，忘了我身上还穿着它。
And then my shirt, and I had to wear it to go, and I went to Whole Foods.
And I realized as I was getting out of the carto...
Why'd you have to wear it?
Because if you took it off, you'd be just in a sweaty...
Well, I'd taken my t-shirt off because it was gone.
It was so soaked in sweat because I work out so hard.
Because if you want to, let me walk you through the workout.
Well, because you're wearing the heavy hands.
然后我的衬衫，我不得不穿着它去，我去了全食超市。当我下车时我意识到……你为什么要穿它？因为如果你把它脱了，你就只剩下一件汗湿的……好吧，我把我的T恤脱了，因为它不见了。它被汗水浸透了，因为我锻炼得太卖力了。因为如果你想的话，让我带你了解一下我的锻炼过程。好吧，因为你戴着重力手环。
You strap on the heavy hands and the heavy ankles, right?
The Velcro.
And I got the big visor that comes down in front and then I got the locked up.
No, because I'm wearing the, you know, I got the weight vest, as we know.
So you're shirtless with a hoodie on.
So anyway, shirtless with the hoodie on.
And then I'm in line.
Smartless hoodie on in holtoots.
你绑上重力手环和重力脚环，对吧？魔术贴。我戴着大遮阳帽，前面挡着，然后我锁上了。不，因为我穿着，你知道的，我穿着负重背心，如你所知。所以你光着上身穿着连帽衫。总之，光着上身穿着连帽衫。然后我在排队。穿着《Smartless》连帽衫在全食超市。
Oh, God.
I hope you're in and up.
somebody you know.
No, I got a guy, I forget the news name.
He always does, like, Getty Images, photos at events.
And he's like, and I just hear it.
I was like, well, it looks like somebody's got Will Arnett on the backwards.
And I turn around with him.
天哪。我希望你没遇到认识的人。不，我遇到了一个家伙，我忘了他的名字。他总是负责活动现场的盖蒂图片社照片。他就像是，我只听到了。我说，看起来有人把威尔·阿奈特穿在背上了。我转过身去面对他。
And I go, luckily, we all kind of know.
I forget his name is a nice guy.
And I was like, oh, shit, at which point.
And then I go up to, I do a self-checkout.
And this girl taps me on their shoulder.
They're like, are you willing to go?
Yeah, and I'm like, really big fan.
And I was like, and I literally said to the stranger, and I said to the stranger, and I
我说，幸运的是，我们都认识。我忘了他的名字，是个好人。我说，哦，该死，在那一刻。然后我走到自助结账台。这个女孩拍了拍我的肩膀。他们说，你是威尔·阿奈特吗？是的，我说，我是你们的忠实粉丝。然后我真的对那个陌生人说了，我对那个陌生人说，我
said to this stranger, I was so embarrassed.
I go, by the way, I never normally would wear this, but I didn't have to.
God, it gets worse.
And I just ran to my car.
I was like, what a tool.
It a deeper sweat.
Then I hope you were locked out of your car, had to call AAA on the side of the road.
Standing on the center of the street.
对那个陌生人说，我太尴尬了。我说，顺便说一句，我平时绝不会穿这个，但我没别的穿了。天哪，情况更糟了。我直接跑回车里。我想，真是个傻瓜。出了一身更深的汗。然后我希望你被锁在车外，不得不叫AAA路边救援。站在街道中央。
I'll wear smartless sweats.
No, we know.
No, to the gym, to the gym.
I know.
Sure.
Or anyway.
But nobody cares.
Nobody stopped.
我会穿《Smartless》的运动裤。不，我们知道。不，去健身房，去健身房。我知道。当然。或者别的什么。但没人会在意。没人拦住我。
It was so humiliated, tapped on the shoulder.
I love the show.
Excuse me, are you Will or net?
Yeah, how's your merch going?
Wait, what's that new tag for Reesis's?
Where you're using the Reesies name for a different word?
Like, it's all, instead of like it's all reality, it's all Reesies, or something like that?
I don't know.
太丢人了，被人拍了拍肩膀。我喜欢这个节目。打扰一下，你是威尔·阿奈特吗？是的，你的周边卖得怎么样？等等，那个瑞茜的新标签是什么？你用瑞茜的名字代替了另一个词？就像，不是“一切皆现实”，而是“一切皆瑞茜”，或者类似的东西？我不知道。
I was impressed with it this weekend.
Yeah, everybody loves the Reeses?
No.
And something like that.
That was exciting.
You were expecting more from that?
I apologize, I'm picking my teeth a little bit.
What is, what, what's the, what's the, don't start now?
这个周末我印象深刻。是的，每个人都喜欢瑞茜？不。类似那样。那很令人兴奋。你对此有更高的期待吗？抱歉，我在剔牙。什么是，什么，什么是，别现在开始？
What's the protocol?
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, the politeness thing.
You guys aren't, aren't both real deep on manners, but I wouldn't mind pulling.
Much more than you are.
I don't know about that.
Yeah.
What about, about, I don't talk about potty stuff.
规矩是什么？是的，我知道。是的，礼貌问题。你们俩对礼仪都不太讲究，但我倒不介意。比你们讲究多了。我对此表示怀疑。是的。关于，关于，我不谈论排泄的事。
I don't, I don't, you don't, you don't, you don't fart.
You don't fart either.
Yeah, of course.
I don't think you've ever farted in front of me.
Well, it's disgusting.
Who wants to hear?
What are you talking about, man?
Oh, listen, that's just, it's just dude shit, you know, bro.
我不，我不，你不会，你不会，你不会放屁。你也不会放屁。是的，当然。我不认为你在我面前放过屁。好吧，那太恶心了。谁想听？你在说什么，伙计？哦，听着，那只是，那只是男人的事，你知道的，兄弟。
Not just dude shoes.
I mean, Sean and I love our power burps.
Sean, I think you and I, I've definitely farted in front of you, Sean.
I think you've definitely farted on me.
Yeah, you've farted in front of me before.
I have, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the car.
不只是男人的事。我是说，肖恩和我喜欢我们的强力打嗝。肖恩，我想你和我，我绝对在你面前放过屁，肖恩。我想你绝对在我身上放过屁。是的，你以前在我面前放过屁。我有，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的。在车里。
But Willie doesn't.
He doesn't.
So then Will, then you don't, you don't, you don't, did you ever poo in front of, um, Amy?
Are you looking for clicks?
No, I'm just saying.
Are you trying to get something that we can click around?
Always forget people listening to this.
Wait, but hang on, you were married to her, had two kids, you guys never went to the bathroom in front of each other?
但威尔不会。他不会。那么威尔，那你不会，你不会，你不会，你有没有在艾米面前拉过屎？你在找点击率吗？不，我只是说说。你是在试图找些我们可以炒作的话题吗？总是忘了有人在听这个。等等，但是等等，你和她结过婚，有两个孩子，你们从来没有在对方面前上过厕所？
I'm sorry, the question is, did I poo in front of Amy?
And you're saying that I don't have manners?
What are you talking about?
It's a good question. It's not a good question. I refuse to answer it.
It's a cute question.
I refuse to answer that.
Did you poo?
抱歉，问题是，我有没有在艾米面前拉过屎？而你说我没有礼貌？你在说什么？这是个好问题。这不是个好问题。我拒绝回答。这是个可爱的问题。我拒绝回答。你拉了吗？你拉了吗？
Yeah.
All right.
I hope we have a very respectable guest on.
Well, let me ask you.
We do, and she's going to be outraged by this, by the way.
But wait a minute.
But wait a minute, do you poo in front of Amanda?
I mean, we don't use the same potty, but...
是的。好吧。我希望我们有一位非常体面的嘉宾。好吧，让我问你。我们有，而且顺便说一下，她会被这个冒犯到的。但等等，但等等，你在阿曼达面前拉屎吗？我是说，我们不用同一个马桶，但是……
Potty, God, if she needed to come in and ask me...
If she needed to come in and ask me something important, she could and would.
I don't know if I would do that to her, although to hear her, she doesn't poo.
Never has.
Right.
I don't know how...
It's amazing.
But, yeah.
马桶，天哪，如果她需要进来问我……如果她需要进来问我什么重要的事情，她可以也会这样做。我不知道我会不会那样对她，尽管听她自己说，她从不拉屎。从来没有。对。我不知道怎么……这太神奇了。但是，是的。
Yeah.
I spoke to her this morning.
She said, please tell him that I'm jealous that we get to see your face and she didn't this morning.
Oh, that's your age.
It's coming up on three weeks.
I know.
When are you back?
We saw her this weekend.
是的。我今天早上和她通过话。她说，请告诉他，我很嫉妒你们能见到他的脸，而我今天早上没见到。哦，那是你的年龄。快三周了。我知道。你什么时候回来？我们这个周末见到她了。
I talked to her yesterday and I saw her Saturday night.
Yeah, we saw her Saturday.
I've been spending a lot of time with her.
Yeah, same.
Yeah.
Well, let me say this.
get home, she is worn out.
我昨天和她谈过，我周六晚上见到她了。是的，我们周六见到她了。我一直花很多时间陪她。是的，我也是。我一直花很多时间陪她。是的。好吧，让我这么说吧。回家时，她精疲力竭。
Just give her a break.
I love, can I just say all, all bits aside,
how much I do love your wife Amanda.
We all do a job.
We all love it.
I was on the phone with her this morning.
She's the fucking greatest.
She's such a good friend.
让她休息一下吧。我爱，我能说吗，抛开所有玩笑，我是多么爱你的妻子阿曼达。我们都爱。我们都爱她。我今天早上和她通了电话。她真是太棒了。她是个这么好的朋友。
She's so thoughtful and kind and sweet.
Always available.
Yeah, she's amazing.
I like her too, pretty much.
She's so, so good.
Tell you's good.
It's always real good.
class in, you're going to feel badly about all this
她那么体贴、善良、甜美。随时都有空。是的，她太棒了。我也很喜欢她，非常喜欢。告诉你她很好。总是非常好。班级里，你会对所有这些
disgusting potty talking. Tell me she's not an
award winner, is she? Oh, well, okay,
well, tell me if this means a lot.
Uh-oh.
Ten Golden Globe nominations
and two wins. Wow.
Seven BAFTA nominations.
Oh, I was going to say, does she have a British accent?
恶心的排泄谈话感到难过。告诉我她不是个获奖者，对吧？哦，好吧，好吧，告诉我这是否意味着什么。噢哦。十项金球奖提名和两次获奖。哇。七项英国电影学院奖提名。哦，我正想说，她有英国口音吗？
Two Emmy Noms.
Ten Sags
nominations and two wins.
I apologize.
Five Academy Award
nominations. Wow.
Christ.
Five Academy Award
两次艾美奖提名。十项演员工会奖提名和两次获奖。我道歉。五项奥斯卡奖提名。哇。天哪。五项奥斯卡奖
nominations.
Do you like films like
Junebug. Do you like films like Night of the Museum?
Julian Julia?
Do you like the master, the Muppets,
on the road? Arrival, Sean.
Oh my God.
Okay, Nightbatch.
提名。你喜欢像《甲壳虫女孩》这样的电影吗？你喜欢像《博物馆奇妙夜》这样的电影吗？《朱莉与朱莉娅》？你喜欢《大师》、《布偶》、《在路上》？《降临》，肖恩。哦，天哪。好吧，夜间批次。
She's fine with the poo talk.
Get around here.
Hi.
I'm so glad I entered on this conversation.
I'm so embarrassed, Amy.
I'm sorry.
No, no, don't be.
她不介意谈论拉屎。她不介意谈论拉屎。过来这边。嗨。我很高兴我加入了这个对话。我太尴尬了，艾米。对不起。不，不，别这样。
We know each other a little.
I know you're good with the poo talk.
I'm fine with poop talk.
Absolutely. And I also love Amanda.
Yeah, she's the best.
Oh, my gosh.
How nice you're here with us, Amy?
I'm so happy to be here.
我们互相了解一点。我知道你对拉屎的话题没意见。我不介意谈论大便。绝对不介意。而且我也爱阿曼达。是的，她是最好的。哦，天哪。你在这里和我们在一起真是太好了，艾米？我很高兴能在这里。
Yes, I'm very glad to get to participate in this conversation.
Important conversation.
Well, jump in if you want.
Yeah, sure.
Welcome.
Here's our new intro.
Pretend that it never happened.
Now we get the...
是的，我很高兴能参与这个对话。重要的对话。好吧，想加入就加入吧。是的，当然。欢迎。这是我们的新开场。假装刚才什么都没发生。现在我们得到……
Guys, it's Amy.
Hi.
Hi, guys.
Amy, where are we finding you today, by the way?
I'm really liking your background.
Los Angeles in my kitchen.
Okay, in your kitchen.
伙计们，是艾米。嗨。嗨。嗨，伙计们。艾米，顺便问一下，你今天在哪里？我真的很喜欢你的背景。洛杉矶，在我的厨房里。好的，在你的厨房里。
So nice.
Yeah.
Amy, I'm going to let Will drive this,
but I'm dying to get to doubt.
Don't worry, he won't.
And arrival,
because those are two of my favorite films ever.
And I've seen Arrival probably,
真好。是的。艾米，我要让威尔来主导，但我迫不及待想聊《降临》。别担心，他不会的。还有《降临》，因为那是我最喜欢的两部电影。我大概看过《降临》……
no joke, probably like 10, 12 times.
It's so good.
Amy, I can't tell you how many times
we've had other people on
who have no connection to a rival
and then China B.
Have you seen a rival?
Yeah.
不开玩笑，大概看了10、12次。太棒了。艾米，我无法告诉你我们有多少次邀请过其他与《降临》毫无关联的人，然后中国B。你看过《降临》吗？是的。
But that script is one of, you know,
not since like, you know,
the sixth sense or something.
Have you read a script or seen a script or seen a movie, whatever,
that has an ending that just completely blows your mind.
I mean, the fact that all the flashbacks were actually flashed forwards is so...
Spoilerly.
You've never seen anything like...
但那个剧本是，你知道的，自《第六感》之类的电影以来，还没有过。你读过剧本或看过剧本或看过电影，无论什么，有一个结局让你完全震惊吗？我是说，所有的闪回实际上都是闪前，这太……剧透了。你从来没见过这样的……
Like, when you read it, were you like, wait a minute, what?
Yeah, I mean, I was reading it sort of thinking it was told in like a traditional timeline,
so I still loved it.
But then when I got to the end, I was like, oh, no, I got to go back and reread it and understand it in a different way.
You almost have to watch the movie again.
Yeah, it's, it was so crazy to shoot it because I had to perform it as if it were, like, it was I had to live in those, in that duality of like letting the audience think that it was flashbacks.
But then on a rewatch, understanding that it was a flash forward.
So that was a lot of fun to play with.
就像，当你读它的时候，你会想，等等，什么？是的，我是说，我读的时候以为它是以传统的时间线讲述的，所以我仍然很喜欢它。但当我读到结尾时，我想，哦，不，我得回去重读一遍，以不同的方式理解它。你几乎必须再看一遍电影。是的，拍摄它太疯狂了，因为我必须表现得好像它是，我必须生活在那双重性中，让观众以为那是闪回。但重看时，理解到那是闪前。所以玩起来很有趣。
So smart.
Yeah, that's so smart.
Yeah, Denise's amazing.
He's so good.
That guy is so good.
And he's lovely.
He's like the nicest.
He was on the podcast, yeah.
太聪明了。是的，太聪明了。是的，丹尼斯太棒了。他太好了。那个家伙太好了。而且他很可爱。他就像最友善的人。他上过这个播客，是的。
Oh, isn't he just like so humble and funny?
and you're like, yeah.
Can you imagine he had to deal with Sean
that whole, the whole podcast?
It was just, it was such a handful.
I was dripping sweat.
And then you did, and then you did the, and then you, and you're like,
and Dune, I'm like, Dune.
哦，他不是那么谦虚和有趣吗？你就像，是的。你能想象他必须应付肖恩整个播客吗？那真是太棘手了。我汗流浃背。然后你做了，然后你做了，然后你，你就像，还有《沙丘》，我就像，《沙丘》。
Yeah.
And then I was the idiot over here calling him Denny the whole time, which is Dennis.
That's all right.
I called him Dennis Villanueva, so there you go.
Villanueva.
Oh, no.
Not to him.
是的。是的。然后我就是那个一直叫他“丹尼”的白痴，其实是“丹尼斯”。没关系。我叫他“丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦”，所以就这样吧。维伦纽瓦。哦，不。不是对他。
I joke to him because that's kind of how it's spelled in sort of the.
Right.
Well.
Colorado, pronoun.
But I was going to say in Colorado, by way of, so I didn't know this, that you were born in Italy.
I was born in Italy.
Which part?
Dad was in the Army.
我对他开玩笑，因为那在某种程度上是拼写方式。对。好吧。科罗拉多，代词。但我正想说在科罗拉多，顺便说一下，我不知道这个，你出生在意大利。我出生在意大利。哪个部分？爸爸在军队。
My dad was stationed at Vicenza and Aviano Air Force Base, and Vicenza Army Base.
So I was born in that region, which is kind of in between Florence and Venice.
Scotty, my husband, Scotty, he's in Army Bratt, too.
He was born in Okinawa, Japan.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, so you guys are like born all over the world.
Exactly.
My husband was born in Ramstein, Germany.
我爸爸驻扎在维琴察和阿维亚诺空军基地，以及维琴察陆军基地。所以我出生在那个地区，介于佛罗伦萨和威尼斯之间。斯科蒂，我的丈夫，斯科蒂，他也是军人子弟。他出生在日本冲绳。哦，哇。是的，所以你们就像出生在世界各地一样。正是如此。我丈夫出生在德国拉姆施泰因。
Oh, wow.
Also, also, also, also, parents in the...
Also, Air Force, yeah.
Also Air Force?
Yeah, his dad was Air Force, so...
Oh, wow, that's cool.
Then how does it work then to get an American passport?
哦，哇。哦，哇。还有，还有，还有，还有，父母在……还有空军，是的。也是空军？是的，他爸爸是空军，所以……哦，哇，那很酷。那怎么才能拿到美国护照呢？
Do you have to, like, sort of, when you come to this country, then what goes on with that?
Well, her parents are American.
So she's an American born to Brun.
You're naturalized.
Because you're born on an American base, yeah.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Can you run for president?
你必须，比如，当你来到这个国家时，那会发生什么？好吧，她的父母是美国人。所以她是出生在国外的美国人。你是归化的。因为你出生在美国基地，是的。正是如此。你能竞选总统吗？
I think I'm I don't think that's in my interest okay I think technically I mean by the way all the rules are at the window on that one I think so are there any rules do that anymore I think I'd be I'd be great I bet you'd be very good yeah I bet you be very good I'd vote for you there'd be a lot of singing in the white house that's for sure yeah that would be lovely so so you're you're born overseas to air force dad and he moved around a
Army Dad. Oh, sorry.
My husband has an Air Force Dad.
Sorry, I'm not that particular, but just in case he is.
I want to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
Of course.
Okay, so Army Dad.
我想我……我不认为那符合我的利益，好吧。我想从技术上讲，顺便说一下，所有的规则在那一点上都过时了。我想是的。还有任何规则吗？我想我会，我会很棒的。我敢打赌你会非常出色。是的，我敢打赌你会非常出色。我会投票给你。白宫里会有很多歌声，那是肯定的。是的，那会很可爱的。所以，所以你出生在海外，空军爸爸，他搬来搬去……陆军爸爸。哦，抱歉。我丈夫有个空军爸爸。抱歉，我没那么挑剔，但以防万一他是。我想。是的，是的，是的，当然。当然。好吧，所以陆军爸爸。
Yeah.
And then you end up basically settling in Colorado, which you mentioned.
Yes.
And then where did the sort of the interest come from to, you know, for performing?
Because you're not just a great performer who does it at the highest level.
You're also prolific.
You've done so much.
是的。然后你基本上在科罗拉多定居，你提到了。是的。是的。然后那种表演的兴趣是从哪里来的？因为你不仅是一位在最高水平上表演的伟大演员。你还多产。你做了这么多。
And so it seems like, where does that come from?
Was your mom into that or was your dad into that?
Were they encouraging?
My dad was a performer.
Oh, wow.
He played, he had a band and sang,
and he ended up being sort of like a one-man band,
and he played in bars,
所以看起来，那来自哪里？你妈妈喜欢那个，还是你爸爸喜欢那个？他们鼓励吗？我爸爸是个表演者。哦，哇。他演奏，他有个乐队并唱歌，他最终成了那种单人乐队，他在酒吧里演奏，
and so we'd go watch him in bars.
Wait, wait, with the symbols tied to the leg and everything.
It wasn't quite Dick Van Dyke, Mary Poppins.
I love that.
No, he had like all.
these synths and he would like push buttons for, yeah.
Bang your knees together for the symbol hit.
所以我们会去看他在酒吧里的表演。等等，等等，脚上绑着镲片什么的。那不太像迪克·范·戴克，《欢乐满人间》。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。不，他有所有这些合成器，他会按下按钮，是的。膝盖撞在一起敲镲。
Yeah, at pizza joints, just walking around, flapping his wings.
Oh, I love that.
They'd just turn them loose for someone's birthday coming out of the kitchen.
I actually wish that's what he did.
That would be great.
No, he would play, there's a foot synthesizer, right?
So I don't know if you guys have ever seen those.
Yeah.
是的，在披萨店，走来走去，拍打着翅膀。哦，我喜欢那个。他们只是在某人生日时把他从厨房里放出来。我其实希望他就是那样做的。那会很棒的。不，他会演奏，有个脚部合成器，对吧？所以我不知道你们有没有见过那些。是的。
So you would wear fancy socks.
play the foot synthesizer.
Come on.
Kind of like big, like the movie Big.
No, it's a...
No.
Isn't it?
It's not like that.
所以你会穿漂亮的袜子。演奏脚部合成器。得了吧。有点像电影《飞越未来》。不，它是个……不。不是吗？它不像那样。
It's literally looks sort of like...
I guess this is what came to mind.
You know in Goonies, that big piano?
Yeah.
That they play with the skeleton bones.
It's like that, but like black.
Blacker.
I don't know.
它看起来确实有点像……我想这就是我想到的。你知道在《七宝奇谋》里，那个大钢琴吗？是的。他们用骨头敲击的那个。就像那样，但像黑色。更黑。我不知道。
That's the best way.
That's the visualization that came...
Is it kind of like the bottom path of an organ?
Like when they push the feet with you.
Yeah, exactly.
So he pushes on these pedals with his feet while he plays.
You saved it, John.
Yeah.
那是最好的方式。那是我想到的画面……它有点像管风琴的底部吗？就像他们用脚推的那种。是的，正是如此。所以他用脚踩这些踏板，同时演奏。你救了场，肖恩。是的。
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
I'm like, it's kind of like the goonies skeleton.
I'm like, imagine if they made big and goonies?
And you're like, imagine if Steve Villeneuve made like goonies and big?
And the person who's making it as watching a rival?
Wait, so, Amy, this doesn't sound like an army dad.
I'm just like, return to the goondocks.
谢谢。谢谢你。我心想，这有点像《七宝奇谋》的骨头。我心想，想象一下如果他们拍了《飞越未来》和《七宝奇谋》？而你就像，想象一下如果史蒂夫·维伦纽瓦拍了《七宝奇谋》和《飞越未来》？而那个制作它的人正在看《降临》？等等，所以，艾米，这听起来不像个陆军爸爸。我只是想，回到古恩多克斯。
All of a sudden, you guys, I'm writing a script to say.
Right.
Yeah, you're right.
Jason's right.
It doesn't sound like a regular army dad.
He can also clean a weapon, too.
I mean, this guy's multi-talented, we're saying.
You're painting a great dynamic picture.
突然之间，你们，我正在写一个剧本。对。是的，你是对的。杰森是对的。这听起来不像个普通的陆军爸爸。他也能清理武器。我是说，这家伙多才多艺，我们是说。你描绘了一幅伟大的动态画面。
Absolutely.
Yeah?
Yeah, but mostly played music.
Wow.
So then that's where you got your...
So then did singing and dancing precede acting?
Yes, yeah.
Absolutely.
绝对。是的？是的，但主要是演奏音乐。哇。所以那就是你得到你的……所以唱歌和跳舞在表演之前吗？是的，是的。绝对。
I never thought I was going to be an actress.
I was such a musical theater kid and mostly trained in ballet, but like I was so shy.
And I had paralyzing stage fright.
Really?
But I make myself do it anyway.
And every time I'm like, why do I do this to myself?
Yeah, it's torture.
But isn't stage fright more acute on a stage doing, singing, dancing, spotlight, microphone.
我从没想过我会成为一名演员。我曾是个音乐剧孩子，主要接受芭蕾训练，但我太害羞了。而且我有瘫痪性的舞台恐惧症。真的吗？但我还是强迫自己去做。每次我都想，我为什么要这样折磨自己？是的，那是折磨。但舞台恐惧症在舞台上表演、唱歌、跳舞、聚光灯、麦克风时不是更严重吗？
It's not cute anywhere.
Isn't the fright more intense there than in front of a camera or no?
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, they still get nervous in front of a camera, but it's such an intimate thing.
And you have one person you can focus on.
And you can screw up.
You can screw up, exactly.
它在任何地方都不可爱。恐惧在那种情况下不是比在摄像机前更强烈吗，还是不是？是的。哦，是的。我是说，他们在摄像机前仍然会紧张，但这是一种非常亲密的事情。而且你有一个可以专注的人。而且你可以搞砸。你可以搞砸，正是如此。
Yeah, and then just do it again.
Now, this is reminding me because I was doing a project.
This is many, many, many, many, many years ago.
Oh, which project was this?
Buckle up.
Sorry, which project were you working on?
I can't say.
No, that's all.
是的，然后重来一遍。现在，这让我想起了，因为我正在做一个项目。这是很多很多很多很多年前的事了。哦，这是哪个项目？系好安全带。抱歉，你在做什么项目？我不能说。不，没关系。
I will applaud.
Go ahead.
And the producers were like, you should reach out to Amy Adams for this project.
And I was like, well, I don't know Amy Adams.
I'm a big fan, but I don't know.
No, just do what she knows you're going to call.
So I called you.
I don't know if you remember this.
我会鼓掌。继续。制片人说，你应该联系艾米·亚当斯做这个项目。我说，嗯，我不认识艾米·亚当斯。我是个大粉丝，但我不知道。不，只要做她知道你会打的电话。所以我给你打了电话。我不知道你还记不记得。
I called you, and you picked up, and you go, hello.
And I go, hi, Amy, it's Sean.
Hayes, oh, I'm in the White House right now in the bathroom. Can I call you back?
Do you remember this?
I was at the White House for Julie and Julia.
Oh, my God.
And that's when I was like, wait, the time I call you, you're in the bathroom at the White House.
Yes, I was in the bathroom at the White House.
我给你打了电话，你接了，你说，喂。我说，嗨，艾米，我是肖恩。海耶斯，哦，我现在在白宫的厕所里。我能回电给你吗？你记得吗？我当时在白宫参加《朱莉与朱莉娅》的活动。哦，我的天哪。那就是我心想，等等，我给你打电话的时候，你在白宫的厕所里。是的，我当时在白宫的厕所里。
That is crazy.
So that was last time you talked to her?
Yeah, that was last time you talked to her.
Yeah, that was last time I talked to Amy. Have you been since?
You know, just hanging out.
Wait, wait, so Amy.
Having a kid.
But what I want to know, oh, yeah, we're going to get into that.
那太疯狂了。所以那是你最后一次和她谈话？是的，那是你最后一次和她谈话。是的，那是最后一次我和艾米谈话。从那以后你们见过吗？你知道，只是闲逛。等等，等等，所以艾米。生了个孩子。但我想要知道的是，哦，是的，我们要聊那个。
But what I want to know is you didn't think you would have a career as an actor.
So, and your dad's doing all these, playing the one-man band in the bars and stuff.
How do you go from that to what's your first acting gig?
And how did that happen?
From Colorado.
Well, I started dancing.
That was sort of my way into performing, which was good because I could be with, like, a group of people.
For me, it's very much about a singular focus.
但我想要知道的是，你没想过你会成为一名演员。所以，你爸爸在酒吧里做单人乐队什么的。你是怎么从那儿走到你的第一份表演工作的？那是怎么发生的？从科罗拉多。好吧，我开始跳舞。那是我进入表演的方式，这很好，因为我可以和一群人在一起。对我来说，这非常关于单一的焦点。
So, like, always being in the chorus was really fun because you got to feed off of everybody else
and just become a part of a group, you know.
Yeah, right.
And I love that.
So, yeah, I got into dancing, which led me after high school.
I was going to say the reason I got into all of it
is because I was bad at math because I wanted to be a doctor.
So I was like, really?
所以，比如，一直在合唱团里真的很有趣，因为你可以从别人身上汲取能量，成为群体的一部分，你知道。是的，对。我喜欢那个。所以，是的，我开始跳舞，这引导我高中毕业后。我正想说我进入这一切的原因是因为我数学不好，因为我想成为一名医生。所以我心想，真的？
Really?
What kind of doctor?
Still wish I could have been a doctor.
I think I wanted to work in emergency medicine.
I'm really good in a crisis.
Yeah.
Really?
真的？什么样的医生？仍然希望我能成为一名医生。我想我想在急诊医学领域工作。我在危机中表现得很好。真的吗？是的。
And you'd be okay with like blood and gore and like somebody in a lot of pain.
Yeah, yeah.
trauma you'd be okay with?
I really, I want to like,
I have this fantasy that when I retire
from acting, I'm going to be one of the seniors
that volunteers down at Cedars.
你会对血腥、暴力和处于剧痛中的人没问题吗？是的，是的。创伤你没问题吗？是的，是的。我真的，我想，我有这种幻想，当我从表演中退休时，我会成为在锡达斯做志愿者的老年人之一。
I was like, I kind of have the same thing.
Do you?
I kind of want to, yeah, like, I want to just go, like,
help people out, like, what's going on?
Well, you're going to be there anyway, so you might as well.
You've got your own parking spot there.
It's a hop, skip and jump.
Wait, that's so interesting.
我心想，我也有同样的想法。你有吗？我有点想，是的，比如，我只想去，比如，帮助人们，比如，发生了什么？好吧，反正你也会在那儿，所以你不如去。你在那儿有自己的停车位。那是一步之遥。等等，那太有趣了。
Are you good?
So, so, because some people are like,
flight instead of fight
during emergencies, right?
They're like, I can't deal with this and they run away.
Whereas, like, there's this one time when I was driving home from a taping of Will and Grace
and a guy was lying in the middle of the street.
This is a sitcom.
你擅长吗？所以，所以，因为有些人比如在紧急情况下是逃跑而不是战斗，对吧？他们说，我处理不了这个，然后他们跑开了。然而，比如有一次我从《威尔与格蕾丝》的录制现场开车回家，一个家伙躺在街道中间。这是一个情景喜剧。
So funny.
So many misunderstandings.
They don't make them.
They don't make them no more.
They're not like that.
Not with the laughs.
And this one thinks this.
And the other one thinks this.
太搞笑了。这么多误解。他们不再拍了。他们不再拍了。不像那样。没有笑声。这个认为那个。那个认为这个。
And they have a misunderstanding.
They have a misunderstanding.
The one door shots.
The other one.
in no analysis in one bed.
Everybody's gay.
Funny.
Sorry, Amy.
他们有误解。他们有误解。单门射击。另一个。在同一张床上没有分析。每个人都是同性恋。有趣。抱歉，艾米。
Sorry about that.
No, I love it.
I love it.
You guys are great.
I'm like sometimes way too earnest,
so I appreciate you guys bringing humorous.
We're not.
We should be, we should learn from you.
抱歉。不，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。你们太棒了。我心想有时太认真了，所以我很感激你们带来幽默。我们不是。我们应该，我们应该向你学习。
No, exactly.
No.
No, so I was driving home from one of the tables
and there's this guy lying in the middle of the street
and I was like, what?
And the two cars ahead of me were just driving around him.
I was like, what?
But this guy's lying in the middle street.
不，正是如此。不。不，所以我从录制现场开车回家，有个家伙躺在街道中间，我心想，什么？我前面的两辆车只是绕过他开了过去。我心想，什么？但这个家伙躺在街道中间。
That was me and well.
On the gas.
Smart.
Just missed his head.
And so I pull over as somebody would do.
And then just as I open the door to my car, I'm like, oh, is this one of those things,
this setup where I get out, I help the guy, and then somebody takes my car or whatever,
or, you know, jumps me or whatever it is.
那是我和威尔。踩油门。聪明。差点撞到他的头。所以我靠边停车，就像别人会做的那样。然后就在我打开车门时，我心想，哦，这是那种陷阱吗，我下车，我帮助那个家伙，然后有人抢了我的车或者别的什么，或者，你知道，袭击我或者别的什么。
So then...
I'd love to see you get taken over by that guy.
I'd rather do the tidying behind the mailbox.
And them just taking your car and your clothes.
By the way.
And just leaving you.
Them tying you up and them not understanding how much you're enjoying it.
And I'm just going, no, stop.
所以然后……我很想看你被那个家伙抢走。我宁愿在邮箱后面整理。他们只是抢走你的车和衣服。顺便说一句。然后把你留下。他们把你绑起来，而他们不理解你有多享受。我只是说，不，停下。
No, ouch.
You don't want these clothes?
Oh, good.
You don't want these.
No, wait.
What?
How am I going to get home naked?
You'll figure it out.
不，哎哟。你不想要这些衣服？哦，好。你不想要这些。不，等等。什么？我怎么赤身裸体回家？你会想出办法的。
Okay.
It's crazy.
All right, so, oh, my God.
So you end up lying in the middle of the road so somebody pulls over it for you.
It's a cycle.
Because now you need a ride.
Sorry, Amy.
So, Amy.
好吧。太疯狂了。好吧，所以，哦，我的天哪。所以你最终躺在路中间，有人为你靠边停车。这是一个循环。因为现在你需要搭车。抱歉，艾米。所以，艾米。
It's okay.
I love it.
You know, I love it.
You're kidding.
I was only a few blocks from home, too.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
没关系。我喜欢它。你知道，我喜欢它。你知道，我喜欢它。你在开玩笑。我离家也只有几个街区。是的。哦，天哪。
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
All right, so.
So you're about to get out of the car.
You think it might be a thing.
But then I was like, but the guy could see us in real pain.
God, this is a long way to go to get to the question.
But I, so I get out, and the guy just got shot.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。好吧，所以。所以你正要下车。你认为这可能是一个陷阱。但后来我心想，但那个人可能真的在痛苦中。天哪，为了得到这个问题走了很远的路。但我，所以我下车了，那个人刚被枪击。
The guy was shot.
Oh, yeah.
And so I did take off my shirt, and I put, I didn't know what I was doing.
like to your point, like emergencies, like, you know, fight or flight.
So I was like, I know, I'm going to do this.
So nobody was around.
And so I took my shirt off.
I put it on the bullet wound on his stomach.
那个人被枪击了。哦，是的。所以我确实脱掉了衬衫，我放，我不知道我在做什么。就像你说的，比如紧急情况，比如，你知道，战斗或逃跑。所以我心想，我知道，我要这样做。所以周围没人。所以我脱掉了衬衫。我把它放在他胃部的弹孔上。
And I was like, hold it over for some pressure, not a turn to it or anything.
Correct.
Well, yeah, a makeshift turning around.
And so I'm telling on 9-1-1 on my phone.
Meanwhile, other people have heard it and now are starting to coming out of their houses, right?
And so they already called too.
And then-
You starting to feel self-conscious about being topless?
我心想，按住它施加压力，而不是止血带什么的。正确。好吧，是的，临时的止血带。所以我正在手机上打9-1-1。同时，其他人听到了，现在开始从房子里出来，对吧？所以他们也已经打了。然后……你开始对赤裸上身感到难为情了吗？
A little bit, a little bit, a little bit.
Were you actually topless?
I was, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so I...
Not everyone wears a undershirt, granddad.
Yeah, go ahead.
And so, yeah, so the guy, I don't know, that's...
So, finally, the ambulance came and everything, and he lived and he was okay, and everything
有一点，有一点，有一点。你真的赤裸上身了吗？我是，是的，是的，是的。所以我……不是每个人都穿内衣，爷爷。是的，继续。所以，是的，所以那个家伙，我不知道，那是……所以，最后，救护车来了，一切，他活了下来，他没事，一切
was fine.
He got the help he needed.
And, but, but, of course, the ambulance guy was like, are you, Shawnee?
No.
With my hand on his stomach.
I was like, yeah.
But anyway, the point is...
Still topless.
都很好。他得到了他需要的帮助。而且，但是，但是，当然，救护车的人说，你是，肖尼？不。我的手放在他的胃上。我心想，是的。但总之，重点是……仍然赤裸上身。
And then we exchange numbers.
No, I'm kidding.
But the point is, yes.
Emergencies, I attack them.
I don't run from them usually.
Yeah, I get very focused.
Like, everything becomes very focused in an emergency.
I'm sorry.
然后我们交换了号码。不，我在开玩笑。但重点是，是的。紧急情况，我攻击它们。我通常不会逃避它们。是的，我变得非常专注。比如，在紧急情况下一切都变得非常专注。抱歉。
Was that whole story about the time that you saved the dude's life?
Yeah.
Just to prove that he runs into a fire instead of away from a fire.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I've come across a couple of scenes where we've been sort of the first people on the scene.
Oh, really?
Really?
那个关于你救了那个家伙命的故事是真的吗？是的。只是为了证明他冲进火场而不是逃离火场。是的，是的，当然。是的。我遇到过几次我们算是现场第一批人的场景。哦，真的吗？真的？
Yeah.
Care to share?
Like where?
We were in Santa Monica and coming out of our favorite restaurant.
And I was with my dad.
And my dad is also very much like that, thankfully.
And these people were screaming and a guy was walking and they're yelling, he's dying.
是的。是的。愿意分享吗？比如在哪里？我们在圣莫尼卡，从我们最喜欢的餐厅出来。我和我爸爸在一起。我爸爸也确实是那样的人，谢天谢地。这些人尖叫着，一个家伙在走，他们大喊，他快死了。
And my husband's like, that's blood.
And I was like, Darren, you stay here with our daughter.
We ran over and he'd been stabbed in the neck.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
So he was bleeding and his friends were freaking out.
So luckily we're going to the beach.
We grabbed towels.
我丈夫说，那是血。我说，达伦，你留在这里陪我们的女儿。我们跑过去，他脖子被刺伤了。哦，天哪。是的。所以他在流血，他的朋友们吓坏了。所以幸运的是我们要去海滩。我们抓了毛巾。
my dad has been on lots of scenes.
I guess he attracts them as well and applied pressure.
And I'm sitting there somehow going,
you need to calm your pulse rate, take a deep breath.
Wow.
I was just so focused.
I was like, the more you struggle,
the faster you're going to bleed, just lay down.
我爸爸去过很多现场。我想他也吸引它们，并施加了压力。我坐在那里，不知怎么地心想，你需要冷静你的脉搏，深呼吸。哇。我当时太专注了。我说，你挣扎得越厉害，你流血就越快，躺下。
Let's elevate this.
We were like just, and yeah.
And then I ran into him a year later.
A guy walks up to me in the restaurant.
He's like, I heard a story that you and your dad
were on the scene of a guy getting stabbed.
And I was like, yeah, yeah, that's so funny.
You heard that story, and he went like that.
让我们抬高这个。我们就像只是，是的。然后我一年后遇到了他。一个家伙在餐厅里向我走来。他说，我听说了一个故事，你和你爸爸在一个人被刺伤的现场。我说，是的，是的，那太有趣了。你听说了那个故事，他就像那样。
And I was him.
Oh, my God, it's you.
And it was him.
No, wow.
Yeah, it was him.
And he was like all teary
and he had his son with him.
Wow.
而我就是他。哦，我的天哪，是你。而那确实是他。不，哇。是的，确实是他。他热泪盈眶，带着他的儿子。哇。
Yeah, it was so crazy.
Did he tell you what the situation was
under which the reason that he got stabbed?
I mean, as far as I could make out,
it was, they had run into an old college friend
and had some drinks and then went to the liquor store.
They were going to go back to someone's house
and he just freaked out.
是的，太疯狂了。他有没有告诉你他被刺伤的情况？我是说，据我所知，是，他们遇到了一个老大学朋友，喝了几杯，然后去了酒铺。他们打算回某人家，然后他就发疯了。
But I don't know kind of what
the whole story.
Wow, wow, wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Would have been great if you and your dad
started singing him a little song to calm him down.
Oh, yeah, like a one-man.
但我不知道整个故事是什么。哇，哇，哇。那太疯狂了。是的。如果你们和你爸爸开始为他唱一首小歌来让他冷静下来，那会很棒的。哦，是的，像个单人乐队。
Yeah.
You had like a little pocket trombone or something.
Can you imagine I just start singing like Jezelle.
Well, your dad's, and you're dancing.
I'm like, stay away.
That's calming, you know.
That is calming.
是的。你有个小长号什么的。是的。你能想象我开始唱像《吉赛尔》那样的歌吗？好吧，你爸爸的，而你在跳舞。我心想，离远点。那很冷静，你知道。那确实很冷静。
Just start singing Mary Poppins.
That would have been nice.
Wow, you really would have been great in an emergency room.
I'm not that smart, but I'm that focused.
You're not smarter than we are.
No, I don't think so.
Have you ever played a medical person?
You know, I did in Dr. Vegas.
只是开始唱《欢乐满人间》。那会很不错的。哇，你在急诊室真的会很棒。我没那么聪明，但我那么专注。你没我们聪明。不，我不这么认为。你演过医疗人员吗？你知道，我在《拉斯维加斯医生》里演过。
I played Rob Lowe's.
Wait a second.
All right.
I need to see this.
Yeah, me too.
And so I went and...
What year did we make this?
2001.
我演了罗伯·洛的。等等。好吧。我需要看看这个。是的，我也是。所以我去了……我们哪一年拍的？2001年。
Actually, it's a good thing.
good story. I was filming and they sent me home and I was mad because I was like, of course,
the one project where you want to stay where they're filming in Vegas when I was like, you know,
30. And when I went home, I got the Junebug audition. And then was filming Junebug when they
reduced my role from, to recurring.
Oh, he's bad. On TV show. On Dr. Vegas. And I was like, I'm good. They're like, you're just going
leave. I'm like, yeah, I'm good.
I'm all set. I've got an indie.
其实，这是个好故事。我当时在拍摄，他们送我回家，我很生气，因为我心想，当然，那个你想留下的项目，他们在拉斯维加斯拍摄，当时我大概30岁。当我回家时，我得到了《甲壳虫女孩》的试镜。然后当他们把我的角色减少到常驻时，我正在拍摄《甲壳虫女孩》。哦，他很坏。在电视节目上。在《拉斯维加斯医生》上。我心想，我很好。他们说，你就要走了。我心想，是的，我很好。我准备好了。我有个独立电影。
Suck it. I just did an indie.
I'm set. I'm just going to go ahead and get
an Academy Award nomination over here, so I'm good.
You want to reduce it?
Yeah.
I had no idea. I just was like,
anyway, it's a long story, but I did
shadow an emergency room doctor.
去死吧。我刚拍了一部独立电影。我准备好了。我打算直接去拿个奥斯卡提名，所以我很好。你想减少它？是的。我不知道。我只是心想，总之，这是一个很长的故事，但我确实跟踪了一位急诊室医生。
Before that part, yeah. Yeah. And I was like,
yeah, yeah, yeah. That's got to be fascinating.
Did you not want to see? Did you see some things you didn't want to see?
I think for me, I was just
fascinated with the stories that kind of really helped me put things into perspective. I know. I'm so
earnest. I told you guys. I just was so grateful and invested in people's personal stories. It's just
I was at, you know, I'm a frequent flyer at the ER in Los Angeles. But you want to give a shout
out to Cedarsford? Do you get a discount? Yeah, Cedar Sine. Yeah. And I was lying there waiting to get
在那部分之前，是的。是的。我心想，是的，是的，是的。那一定很迷人。你不想看吗？你看到了一些你不想看的东西吗？我想对我来说，我只是被那些真正帮助我把事情看透的故事所吸引。我知道。我太认真了。我告诉过你们。我只是非常感激并投入到人们的个人故事中。我只是，你知道，我是洛杉矶急诊室的常客。但你想给锡达斯福德打个招呼吗？你有折扣吗？是的，锡达斯西奈。是的。我躺在那里等着……
extra couple of punches on your punch card. You'd get to your bonus earlier.
for the cafeteria.
Sean's nickname is Paddles, by the way.
This is true, Amy.
Because I get AFib and they zap my heart back.
Anyway, but one time I was in there,
this was like two years ago,
and the guy, some guy, OD'd on drugs,
在你的打卡卡上多打几个孔。你会更早达到你的奖金。为了自助餐厅。顺便说一下，肖恩的绰号是“桨”。这是真的，艾米。因为我有房颤，他们电击我的心脏恢复。总之，但有一次我在那里，那是大概两年前，那个家伙，某个家伙，吸毒过量，
they were trying to revive him,
and he died right next to me in the room right next to me.
It's so crazy to witness all that.
Willie and I play golf with Dr. Gary Shalman.
He does an ER doctor,
and the things that he knows,
had a do, and he could save any life you put in front of him.
I think it's incredible.
他们试图复苏他，他就在我隔壁的房间里死了。目睹这一切太疯狂了。威利和我与加里·沙尔曼医生打高尔夫。他是个急诊室医生，他知道的事情，必须做，他能救他面前的任何生命。我认为这太不可思议了。
Yeah, it's really amazing.
And he's got a great short game, too.
You can get up and down from anywhere, really.
By the way, let's be clear, he's got a great game all around.
He's middle of the fair way.
Long game, yeah.
I never see him in trouble.
He never see him looking for a ball.
是的，这真的很神奇。而且他的短杆也很好。你真的可以从任何地方上下。顺便说一句，我们要清楚，他各方面都很棒。他在球道中间。长杆，是的。我从没见他陷入麻烦。从没见他找球。
Never.
You want him as your teammate.
Yeah, Dr. Gary's been playing with the same ball for three years, definitely.
Anyway, let's ask him.
Shout out to Dr. Gary.
You know, so, Amy, you've done so many things,
but so many different kinds of roles, like comedy, drama, sci-fi.
Is there one I've seen the most is enchantment?
从没。你想让他做你的队友。是的，加里医生三年来一直用同一个球打球，绝对。总之，让我们问问他。向加里医生致敬。你知道，所以，艾米，你做过很多事情，但很多不同种类的角色，比如喜剧、剧情、科幻。有一个我看得最多的是《魔法奇缘》？
Enchanted?
Or enchanted.
You nailed it.
You never saw enchantment because it doesn't exist.
Yeah, I mean, you know, having two girls, you met both of them.
Yeah, how are they doing?
They must be.
They're doing great.
《魔法奇缘》？或者《魔法奇缘》。你说对了。你从来没看过《魔法奇缘》，因为它不存在。是的，我是说，你知道，有两个女孩，你见过她们俩。是的，她们怎么样？她们一定……她们很好。
Thanks, yeah.
They're not watching it anymore.
Yeah, but I mean, I knew that album backwards and forwards.
Loved it.
Thank you, and I'm sorry.
Yeah, no, no, no.
It was fantastic.
But I've seen them all, but that one a lot.
谢谢，是的。她们不再看了。是的，但我是说，我把那张专辑倒背如流。很喜欢。谢谢，我很抱歉。是的，不，不，不。那太棒了。但我都看过，但那部看了很多。
I bet, yeah.
Yeah, very good.
Thank you.
Do you have, do you have like a genre that you like doing more than,
because you kind of, you've done, like I said, you've done it all.
Like you do, you work in comedy, you work in drama, you work in sci-fi.
Like, is there one sort of lane that you feel more comfortable in?
Or do you just kind of, each one?
我敢打赌，是的。是的，非常好。谢谢。你有，你有你更喜欢做的类型吗，因为你有点，就像我说的，你都做过。比如你做喜剧，你做剧情，你做科幻。比如，有一个你觉得更舒服的领域吗？还是你只是，每一个……
is just like a new opportunity to have fun and you don't really think about it.
Yeah, I think each one's a new opportunity.
I like working in different genres because it requires like a different approach to tone and it's a challenge.
But I mean, I'm most comfortable in like musical theater even at 51 if someone's like,
you need to go play Bell.
I'd be like, got it.
Like that's like, that's where my like spirit lives.
My like younger, my inner child.
都只是一个享受乐趣的新机会，你并没有真正考虑它。是的，我认为每一个都是一个新机会。我喜欢在不同的类型中工作，因为它需要对基调有不同的处理，这是一种挑战。但我是说，我在音乐剧中感觉最舒服，即使在51岁，如果有人说，你需要去演贝尔。我会说，明白了。就像，那是，那是我的精神所在。我的，我的内心小孩。
Do you want to do more of it?
I do.
I did theater recently in the same.
London, and I really do want to do more of it, but I think I'm so tired all this time.
It's so much work. I have so much respect for everybody who works on stage because doing that
age shows a week is really, really grueling. And so I'd have to really consider it. Maybe when my
daughter is a little older. Gets little when she's out of the house because I really want to be
present for her. How old is she? She's going to be 16 next Friday. Oh, wow. Yeah. That's amazing,
你想多做一点吗？我想。我最近在伦敦演了舞台剧，我确实想多演一些，但我总是觉得太累了。那工作量太大了。我非常尊重每一位在舞台上工作的人，因为一周演八场戏真的非常非常折磨人。所以我得好好考虑一下。也许等我女儿再大一点吧。等她离家独立之后，因为我真的很想多陪陪她。她多大了？下周五她就16岁了。哦，哇。太棒了。
I know. How are those driving lessons going?
She has not started them yet.
No.
You haven't taken her out in your car and just like in an open parking lot and said, and just put her in the seat?
Not yet.
No.
I am definitely, she has absolutely.
No interest.
我知道。她的驾驶课上得怎么样了？她还没开始呢。不。你还没带她去空旷的停车场，让她坐在驾驶座上练练吗？还没。不。我肯定，她绝对。一点兴趣都没有。
No, she has interest.
But she wants to get through finals before she starts studying for her permits test because she.
Yeah.
Disciplined.
That's disciplined.
Yeah, but this generation, though, is because of Uber.
There's just, there's no.
That's true.
不，她有兴趣。但她想先考完期末考试，再开始准备驾照笔试，因为她。对，很有自律性。那确实很有自律。是啊，不过这一代人，是因为有优步（Uber）。根本就没必要。那是真的。
I didn't think of that.
When we were kids, remember, like, the day?
The morning you turn 16, you're at the DMV.
No, my guys did.
Arch got it immediately, but Abe's been kind of putting it.
Well, he can only get his learners because he's not 16 yet.
You know what I thought would never happen, though, is that because Jason's right, when you turn 16, you're like, it signifies independence driving, right?
Freeing.
我没想到这一点。我们小时候，记得吗？16岁生日那天早上，你就已经在车管所（DMV）门口了。不，我那几个孩子是。阿奇（Arch）立刻就去考了，但阿比（Abe）一直拖着。好吧，他只能先拿学习驾照，因为他还没满16岁。你知道我以为永远不会改变的是什么吗？杰森说得对，当你16岁时，开车象征着独立，对吧？一种解脱。
But now, and I thought, well, that will never go away, but with Waymo self-driving cars and Uber and stuff, maybe it's not a thing anymore.
I don't know with kids.
Yeah, but it is nice to be able to just like walk outside your house
and climb into your car and go.
It is.
I think she's really going to love that sensation
when she sort of gets into it,
but I respect, I'm letting her...
但现在，我原以为这永远不会改变，但有了Waymo自动驾驶汽车和优步之类的东西，也许这不再是必须的了。我不知道现在的孩子怎么想。是啊，但能直接走出家门，坐进自己的车里出发，这种感觉还是很好的。确实。我想她一旦开始开车，一定会爱上那种感觉，但我尊重她，我让她自己……
Are you still in driving her around mode,
or is she leaning on the UBS like everybody?
A little of both.
I mean, we're a little more cautious with Ubers
as long as she's with friends and stuff like that.
But she loves a Waymo.
That's her thing.
Yeah, we always say it's a known thing, Amy.
你现在还是那种负责接送她的模式，还是像其他人一样，她也开始依赖优步了？两者都有吧。我的意思是，只要她和朋友在一起，我们对优步还是比较谨慎的。但她很喜欢Waymo。那是她的最爱。是啊，我们总是说，艾米，这是众所周知的。
that Jason has the personality of a Waymo driver.
That's just kind of known around the office here.
Just around the office here.
A Waymo driver.
That's enough, Sean.
So funny.
By the way, by the way, I was going to save this.
Sean, I think you know this,
杰森有着Waymo司机的性格。这在我们办公室里是众所周知的。只是在我们办公室里。Waymo司机。够了，肖恩。太搞笑了。顺便说一下，顺便说一下，我本来想留着这个说的。肖恩，我想你知道这个，
and you're going to freak out again on Amy.
You know, she's in the new,
she just wrapped the new Star Wars.
right.
What do you mean?
The one with Ryan Gossling?
Yeah.
Wait, I was on that set.
你又要对艾米大惊小怪了。你知道，她参演了新的《星球大战》，她刚拍完。对。你什么意思？就是瑞恩·高斯林演的那部？对。等等，我在那个片场。
Okay, cool.
Oh, amazing.
Yeah, Sean Levy asked us to come visit, and we visited it for like a day.
What if you found out that Amy knew you were coming in?
She was like, this guy fucking called me once in the toilet at the White House.
This guy won't leave me alone.
I had a very small part.
Yeah.
好吧，酷。哦，太棒了。是啊，肖恩·利维（Sean Levy）邀请我们去参观，我们去待了一天。如果你发现艾米知道你要去会怎样？她可能会说：“这家伙在白宫厕所里给我打过电话。这家伙没完没了。”我当时有个很小的角色。是啊。
You did.
Wait, are you a fan or no?
Oh, my gosh, yeah.
Yeah, huge.
Absolutely.
By the way, Tatooine.
I mean, amazing.
My Cat-A-Hat-Hat-on.
你确实有。等等，你是粉丝吗？哦，天哪，是啊。是的，超级粉丝。绝对是。顺便说一下，塔图因（Tatooine）。我的天，太棒了。我戴着我的塔图因帽子。
I love it.
I have my-Tat-Lead-Hat-on.
Do you go to May the Fourth Disney events at Disney?
Because I've always wanted to go.
Maybe next year you and I will figure it out.
Oh, my God, I would love it.
Leave the kids at home.
Am I right?
我喜欢。我戴着我的塔图因帽子。你会去迪士尼参加5月4日的活动吗？因为我一直想去。也许明年你和我可以一起去。哦，天哪，我太想去了。把孩子们留在家里，对吧？
You're right.
I hate the May the Fourth be with you because that's my birthday.
That's Wilburne.
You're so lucky.
No, I'm not.
They took it over.
Everybody's like, May the Fourth.
I'm like, enough.
你说得对。我讨厌“愿原力与你同在”（May the Fourth be with you），因为那是我的生日。那是威尔伯恩（Wilburne）。你太幸运了。不，我才不。他们把它占用了。每个人都说“5月4日快乐”，我就想，够了。
Wait, did you get to hold all the props
and whatever and all the fantasy stuff.
I love that.
Yeah, I went to the creature shop too.
Isn't that one?
等等，你有机会接触所有的道具和那些奇幻的东西吗？我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。是啊，我也去了生物制作室。那不是很酷吗？
Oh, cool.
I was so cool.
Watch the battles.
I saw the new, you know,
their version of R2D2 and the new one,
which I couldn't post.
We're not allowed to post.
Is he real?
哦，酷。我太酷了。看着那些战斗场面。我看到了新的，你知道，他们版本的R2D2，新的那个，我不能发照片。我们不被允许发布。它是真的吗？
We just racked focus.
There's Scotty in the back just heating up the paddles.
We're rubbing them together.
Getting them ready.
Oh, he's talking about the creatures.
your shop.
Charge!
Wasn't that?
我们刚调好焦距。斯科蒂（Scotty）在后面加热那些桨。我们把它们摩擦在一起。准备好。哦，他在说生物制作室。冲啊！不是吗？
But, and then the guy, I met the guy who created BV8.
Yeah.
That's wild.
It's so cool.
It's wild.
I mean, I'll talk about this, I'm sure, down the road, but like, I don't know what
I'm allowed to talk about, but I was so nervous the first day of working, like, I forgot
但是，然后那个人，我见到了创造BV8的人。是啊。是啊。太疯狂了。太酷了。太疯狂了。我的意思是，我以后肯定会谈到这个，但我不知道我被允许谈论什么，但我第一天工作时太紧张了，我甚至忘了
how to act.
I'm sure Sean Levy's like, Amy, are you okay?
And I'm like, no.
I'm just not okay.
You're just because of all the stuff that was around you and like, what were this?
No, just like, I'm on a Star Wars set.
I know, right?
Yeah.
怎么演戏了。我敢肯定肖恩·利维会说：“艾米，你还好吗？”我说：“不。我只是不太好。”你是因为周围所有的东西，还有，那是什么？不，只是因为我在《星球大战》的片场。我知道，对吧？是啊。
I grew up on this.
This is like, I was like.
I have to now get out of my, like, dorky fan girl place
and go into, like, professional actress
and, like, combining the two was really hard.
So I had to, like...
Could you feel it?
Was it, was it palpable?
我是看着这个长大的。我当时就像。我现在必须从那种书呆子粉丝的状态中走出来，进入专业演员的状态，把两者结合起来真的很难。所以我不得不……你能感觉到吗？它是，它是显而易见的吗？
I mean, were the sets big?
Was the, what the camera gear, like, all, like...
It's so cool, you guys.
It's just so cool.
I'm, like, not allowed to talk about anything, of course,
but I can tell you, it's so cool.
And the kid in it is so great.
I just...
我的意思是，布景很大吗？摄像器材，像，所有，像……太酷了，伙计们。真的太酷了。当然，我不被允许谈论任何事情，但我可以告诉你，这太酷了。里面的那个孩子太棒了。我只是……
What about, what about, like, was there a lot of,
like were the sets real?
Were the weapons real?
Was it all like sort of green screens and, you know?
It's a mix, but it's...
A mix, yeah.
It was, it's enough to like get the feels.
You know what I mean?
那，那，像，布景是真的吗？武器是真的吗？是不是都是那种绿幕，你知道的？是混合的，但它是……混合的，是啊。足以让你有那种感觉。你知道我的意思吗？
And then you got the great Sean Levy there,
just like he's so infectious with his energy and enthusiasm
and his kindness.
And speaking of arrival, he was one of the producers on arrival.
He was?
Yeah, I worked with him at night at the museum.
Oh, that's crazy.
Yeah.
然后你有伟大的肖恩·利维在那里，他那种活力、热情和善良太有感染力了。说到《降临》，他就是《降临》的制片人之一。他是吗？是啊，我和他在《博物馆奇妙夜》合作过。哦，那太疯狂了。是啊。
So you do the Star Wars,
and then you got another,
you got a sci-fi film
coming out later this year
that you did with our buddy Tyca.
What's that?
Right?
是啊。所以你拍了《星球大战》，然后你今年晚些时候还有另一部科幻电影要上映，是你和我们的伙伴塔伊加（Tyca）一起拍的。那是什么？对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
I was like I do.
I was like, yes, yes.
Yeah, we did that like over two years ago now, so yeah.
Wow.
Are you a sci-fi fan?
I do like sci-fi, yeah.
There's such a, you have, like,
是啊，是啊。我当时想，我拍了。我当时想，是的，是的。是啊，我们那是两年前拍的了，所以是的。哇。你是科幻迷吗？我确实喜欢科幻，是的。你有那种，你有那种，
so, like, Star Wars-y sci-fi.
Like, this is, like, seems to be the genre
that you're very comfortable in.
Superman.
Oh, I love it.
I love it.
Yeah.
But she's funny as hell, too.
那种，像《星球大战》式的科幻。这似乎是你非常适应的类型。超人。哦，我喜欢。我喜欢。是啊。但她也非常幽默。
And can sing and dance.
And we haven't even gotten to the drama part of it all.
I mean, I do.
I do love a good drama.
Do you want to leave any for anybody else?
Like, what's going on?
I mean, how great were you in doubt?
I saw that play and I was like, wow, this plays one of the best plays.
而且能歌善舞。我们甚至还没谈到戏剧的部分。我的意思是，我确实，我确实喜欢一部好的戏剧。你想给别人留点机会吗？怎么回事？我的意思是，你在《虐童疑云》（Doubt）里演得有多棒？我看了那部戏，我想，哇，这部戏是最好的戏剧之一。
And then the movie with you and Meryl Streep and.
How good are Meryl and Philip in that?
Getting to sit through the rehearsals with them was, it's my entire actor training.
Like, I never went to college or conservatory.
So I really feel like that.
That was how I learned how to act.
And everybody showed up on set off book, probably.
Just nobody has side, right?
还有你和梅丽尔·斯特里普（Meryl Streep）演的那部电影。梅丽尔和菲利普（Philip）在里面演得有多好？能坐在那里看他们排练，那是我全部的演员训练。我从来没上过大学或戏剧学院。所以我真的觉得，那就是我学习演戏的方式。而且每个人到片场时都背熟了台词，大概吧。没人拿剧本，对吧？
Everybody just knows their stuff.
Oh, yeah.
By that time, we really knew it.
Yeah.
I mean, it's Merrill.
Was it a lot of rehearsal for that film?
More than usual?
I would say so, yeah.
每个人都知道自己的东西。哦，是的。到那时，我们真的都知道了。我的意思是，那是梅丽尔。那部电影排练了很多吗？比平时多吗？我会说是的，是的。
Yeah.
It was a while ago.
It was amazing.
So then, wait, did you just say that you did not go to drama school?
I did not, no.
No.
And so what would you attribute your,
your talent too?
是啊。那是很久以前的事了。太棒了。等等，你刚才说你没上过戏剧学校？我没有，不。不。那你把你的，你的天赋归功于什么？
Was it just a lonely childhood?
Yeah, how'd you get so talented?
A lonely childhood.
It's just like an innate, an innate sense of what would be...
I don't know. I think I've always just been,
I read a lot and I've always been plugged into characters and how and why and what motivates
them and all of that. And I think it just sort of started translating into acting.
I honestly, I also, when I moved to L.A., started working with
是因为孤独的童年吗？是啊，你怎么变得这么有天赋？孤独的童年。这只是一种天生的，一种天生的感觉，关于什么是……我不知道。我想我一直都是这样，我读了很多书，我一直都能融入角色，了解他们如何、为什么以及是什么激励了他们，所有这些。我想这只是开始转化为表演。老实说，当我搬到洛杉矶时，我开始和
an acting coach
later on after I'd started working.
And that was really helpful
because she helped sort of ground me a bit more
instead of van very big.
So that was good.
Well, that's what I was going to say, yeah,
because theater is sort of at odds
一位表演教练合作，是在我开始工作之后。这真的很有帮助，因为她帮我稍微扎实了一点，而不是太夸张。所以那很好。嗯，这就是我想说的，是的，因为戏剧有时与
with your incredible level of subtlety
when you're doing on-camera work.
You know what I mean?
It's just, it's just masterful
how little you have the discipline to do.
Which, you know, if you did that on stage,
the people in the front row would be able to read it,
but that'd be about it, you know?
你在镜头前工作时那种令人难以置信的微妙程度不符。你知道我的意思吗？这只是，这只是大师级的，你有多大的自律去做到这一点。这，你知道，如果你在舞台上那样做，前排的人可能能看出来，但也就仅此而已，你知道吗？
Yeah.
I mean, it's great.
Thank you.
Oftentimes you'll see theater actors that are sometimes
maybe just a little bit bigger on screen.
Right.
But you do not suffer that at all.
It's really, really impressive.
是啊。我的意思是，这太棒了。谢谢。你经常会看到戏剧演员在银幕上表现得稍微夸张一点。对。但你完全没有这个问题。这真的，真的令人印象深刻。
Well, I absolutely love people's inner life.
Like, if I could know what people were thinking at all times,
I'd be so happy.
That's what I love about watching your performance.
It's like, yeah, I lean in and I try to read your mind.
You know, there's stuff going on inside as opposed to you.
You've got to watch this new doc that's coming out later this year.
I was telling Shawnee about it that's called,
嗯，我绝对喜欢人们的内心世界。如果我能随时知道人们在想什么，我会非常高兴。这就是我喜欢看你表演的原因。就像，是的，我倾身向前，试图读懂你的心思。你知道，内心有东西在发生，而不是你。你一定要看今年晚些时候要出的新纪录片。我正跟肖尼（Shawnee）说呢，叫，
this based on the podcast, that really popular podcast,
the telepathy tapes about the nonverbal.
There's a doc.
I just saw a screening of the dock.
Is it good?
It's unbelievable.
Wait, what is it?
Dude, this is a really popular podcast.
这是基于那个播客，那个非常受欢迎的播客，《心灵感应磁带》（The Telepathy Tapes），关于非语言交流的。有一部纪录片。我刚看了纪录片的试映。它好吗？简直不可思议。等等，那是什么？伙计，这是一个非常受欢迎的播客。
Yeah.
And called the telepathy tapes,
and they made a dock at the same time,
and it's coming out later this year.
And it's unbelievable.
I'd goosebumps the entire time watching it.
talking about people who can talk. It was real popular at the same time the Richard Simmons podcast.
Sean, stop mentioning the Richard Simmons. Every time I mention this, Sean brings up the Richard Simmons
是啊。叫《心灵感应磁带》，他们同时制作了一部纪录片，今年晚些时候上映。简直不可思议。我看完的时候全程起鸡皮疙瘩。谈论那些能说话的人。它和理查德·西蒙斯（Richard Simmons）的播客在同一时间非常受欢迎。肖恩，别再提理查德·西蒙斯了。每次我提到这个，肖恩就提起理查德·西蒙斯
podcast, I swear to God. Sean, why? No, how would that be? Leave it.
Leave it. Yeah, an easy reference for everyone. Yeah, let it stand on its own. Let it stand on
its own. Why do you have to mention the fucking Richard Simmons podcast every time? Because at that time
was years and years ago, those were the two most popular. I've never heard of it.
Richard Simmons podcast.
Oh, God, you would love it.
It's so wild.
Oh, here we go.
播客，我发誓。肖恩，为什么？不，那会怎么样？别提了。别提了。是啊，对每个人来说都是一个简单的参考。是啊，让它独立存在吧。让它独立存在吧。为什么你每次都要提那个该死的理查德·西蒙斯播客？因为那是几年前的事了，那是两个最受欢迎的。我从来没听说过。理查德·西蒙斯播客。哦，天哪，你会喜欢的。太疯狂了。哦，开始了。
Oh, fucking fuck's sake, man.
Now, wait, Willie, the reason that you were seeing this earlier than when it's coming out
is because that makes me think maybe we're going to have somebody from it on the podcast coming up.
Did you get a little early link or something?
I don't know.
There's a guest coming.
Look at you putting some stuff together.
哦，该死的，伙计。等等，威利（Willie），你比它上映时间更早看到的原因是，这让我觉得也许我们很快会在播客上请到里面的人。你是不是拿到了什么提前链接之类的？我不知道。我不知道。有嘉宾要来。看看你，把一些东西拼凑在一起。
I used to be a cop.
I know.
Look at you.
Honestly, you guys, it's so fast.
fascinating.
And Amy,
talking about, like,
people understanding
我以前是个警察。我知道。看看你。老实说，伙计们，这太迷人了。艾米，谈到人们理解
what other people
are thinking and stuff.
It is a fucking mind-blower.
Did you listen to that, Amy?
Did you listen to that podcast?
Yeah, I did, actually.
I listened to,
I didn't get towards the end
别人在想什么之类的。这真是太让人震惊了。你听了吗，艾米？你听那个播客了吗？是啊，我听了，其实。我听了，我没听到《心灵感应》的结尾。
of the telepathy.
It started to get,
I don't want to, you know,
it started to get a little,
like, it twisted a bit.
I don't want to give any spoilers.
Yeah, but it's,
it's, I found it.
它开始变得，我不想，你知道，它开始变得有点，它扭曲了一点。我不想剧透。是啊，但它，它，我发现了。
I mean, it was just stunning,
and I'd listen to the podcast, too.
But anyway, yeah, yeah,
I don't know how we got here,
but boy, it's good.
It's really good.
So this is what I was going to say.
What was your first pro gig as an actor?
我的意思是，它太震撼了，我也听了那个播客。但总之，是啊，是啊，我不知道我们是怎么聊到这儿的，但天哪，它很好。真的很好。所以这就是我想说的。你作为演员的第一份专业工作是什么？
Your first paying job?
Like exclusively as an actor?
Does a dancer like...
As an actor, actor, actor.
What was your first...
Actor, actor.
I did a commercial for Omaha National Bank.
Okay.
你的第一份带薪工作？像专门作为演员？舞蹈演员算吗……作为演员，演员，演员。你的第一份……演员，演员。我拍了一个奥马哈国家银行（Omaha National Bank）的广告。好吧。
Where I lip synced.
So I guess it's...
I mean, it's, I'm lip synced to summer loving, but turned into summer banking.
No, no.
Had me a blast.
Yeah.
Sure.
Summer banking, had me a blast.
我在里面对口型。所以我猜它是……我的意思是，它是，我对口型唱《Summer Loving》，但变成了《Summer Banking》。不，不。度过了愉快的时光。是啊。当然。夏季银行业务，度过了愉快的时光。
Bo, bow.
Wow.
But then when I started, I was cast in Drop Dead Gorgeous out of Minnesota.
So that was like my first, like thing.
First thing.
And then what was your first, like, what was your first?
Did you do like a lot of, because I know, obviously you did Dr. Vegas.
We all know that.
砰，砰。哇。但后来我开始工作时，我在明尼苏达州被选中出演《美丽比基尼》（Drop Dead Gorgeous）。所以那是我第一件，像那样的事情。第一件事。然后你的第一份，像，你的第一份？你做了很多，因为我知道，显然你演了《拉斯维加斯医生》（Dr. Vegas）。我们都知道。
We're talking about Rob Lowe.
I still call him Dr. Vegas.
Yeah.
What was your first, like, did you start doing guest spots on shows?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah?
I did all the guest spots.
I was on Charmed.
我们在谈论罗伯·劳（Rob Lowe）。我还是叫他《拉斯维加斯医生》。是啊。你的第一份，像，你开始在节目里客串了吗？哦，是啊，是啊。是吗？我做了所有的客串。我演了《圣女魔咒》（Charmed）。
I was on Buffy.
I was on that 70 show.
Yeah.
West Wing.
Oh, wow.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
What was the point when you figured that you might be safe,
我演了《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》（Buffy）。我演了《70年代秀》（That 70s Show）。是啊。《白宫风云》（West Wing）。哦，哇。我们马上回来。回到节目。你什么时候意识到你可能安全了，
you might not need to have to study something else or have a second job or when did it, when did it seem yesterday?
You could make a living.
I think it was after, I think it was after Enchanted.
Yeah, because that was a big movie, yeah.
It's funny because by the time Enchanted came out, I'd been nominated, but I still didn't see that as like anything that cemented me as secure.
I just saw that as like an amazing, like one-off.
But having the box office of Enchanted, right?
That was a different thing with that, isn't it?
你可能不需要去学别的东西或者找第二份工作，或者什么时候看起来，什么时候看起来昨天？你可以以此为生。我想是在，我想是在《魔法奇缘》（Enchanted）之后。是啊，因为那是一部大电影，是啊。很有趣，因为在《魔法奇缘》上映时，我已经获得过提名了，但我仍然没觉得那有什么让我感到稳固的东西。我只是把它看作是一个惊人的，一次性的机会。但拥有《魔法奇缘》的票房，对吧？那是另一回事，不是吗？
And I also think it was like the most confident at that point I'd ever been in a role.
Because even when I read the script, and I am not somebody who says this, I looked at my husband and went, I don't know who else are going to get for this.
Like, I just was like, no, no, no, no.
And I honestly, I'm not that person.
I would cast someone else in every role I've done.
Like, I'm not competitive like that.
But I read that one and was like, well, this is mine.
Just because I felt like I really understood that world and the duality of her.
而且我也觉得那是我当时在角色中最自信的一次。因为即使当我读剧本时，我不是那种会这么说的人，我看着我丈夫说，我不知道他们还能找谁来演这个。就像，我只是觉得，不，不，不，不。老实说，我不是那种人。我演过的每个角色，我都会选别人来演。就像，我没有那么好胜。但我读了那个剧本，觉得，嗯，这是我的。只是因为我觉得我真的理解那个世界和她的双重性。
But then you also do like, and then you go on to do a couple films with David O'Russell, some gritty films.
You do The Fighter, which is super gritty in such a great film.
Yeah, David, that was huge because David really, I say take a chance, but no one really saw me that way.
And then there was something about an interactive.
action he had with me that kind of was like, wait.
You got in his face about like a valet ticket or something.
You're terrifying.
No. No, I think he just...
但后来你也做，然后你继续拍了几部大卫·O·拉塞尔（David O. Russell）的电影，一些坚韧的电影。你拍了《斗士》（The Fighter），那是非常坚韧且伟大的电影。是啊，大卫，那太重要了，因为大卫真的，我说冒险，但没人真的那样看我。然后他和我之间有一些互动，那种感觉就像，等等。你因为代客泊车票之类的东西和他吵架了。你太可怕了。不。不，我想他只是……
I was here first.
Yeah, something like that.
Wait, was David, did you stab David O. Russell on the neck and then you and your dad saved him?
Is that what happened?
No, it was not David O. Russell.
So you were surprised when David called you with that?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was.
我先来的。是啊，类似那样。等等，大卫，当你接到大卫·O·拉塞尔的电话时，你感到惊讶吗？是啊。是啊，我是。
I was like to say, I have like such memories of where I was when things happened that were huge for me.
and I was in Ireland filming leap year,
like this romantic comedy,
which helped me learn that I was not good at romantic comedy,
though I loved the film.
I just was like, there are people who are really good at this,
and I don't think that's me.
I don't think...
我当时就像，我有那种记忆，关于当那些对我来说巨大的事情发生时我在哪里。我当时在爱尔兰拍摄《闰年》（Leap Year），那部浪漫喜剧，它帮我了解到我不擅长浪漫喜剧，尽管我很喜欢那部电影。我只是觉得，有些人真的很擅长这个，我不觉得那是我。我不觉得……
There's nothing you're not good at.
Yeah, come on.
No, it's just, I'm too earnest.
Like, I want to turn it into, like, Wuthering Heights,
and, like, I just don't have that turn of phrase
that some people are so good at.
I'm just so earnest.
It's so irritating.
没有什么你不擅长的。是啊，得了吧。不，只是，我太认真了。就像，我想把它变成，像《呼啸山庄》（Wuthering Heights），而且，我只是没有那种有些人很擅长的措辞。我只是太认真了。太烦人了。
I've learned to accept it.
What about, what about, did your, did your eyes light up like mine would,
if I got a call from Paul Thomas Anderson?
Like, the master's one of my favorite, favorite films ever.
The master was great.
Paul is one of those people that I will forever want to impress.
It doesn't matter what I'm doing, what I'm saying, a text.
I am just, I just love him so much.
我已经学会接受它了。那，那，你的眼睛会像我一样发光吗，如果我接到保罗·托马斯·安德森（Paul Thomas Anderson）的电话？就像，《大师》（The Master）是我最喜欢的电影之一。大师真的很棒。保罗是那种我永远想给他留下深刻印象的人。不管我在做什么，我在说什么，一条短信。我只是，我只是太爱他了。
Just as a person, too.
Agreed.
Yeah.
I actually met him at a house party.
And I kind of ran the riot act because he had, he had, it's a lot, I don't want to get Paul in trouble, but he had.
He took the last piece of pizza.
作为一个人的话，也是。同意。是啊。是啊。我其实是在一个家庭聚会上见到他的。是啊。我当时有点严厉，因为他有，他有，这很多，我不想让保罗惹麻烦，但他有。他拿了最后一块披萨。
No, no, there was a mutual friend that was a little drunk and acting, a little silly, and he was encouraging it, you know, having fun.
And I was like, that is highly irresponsible.
Now, to be fair, I was 10 weeks pregnant.
And I was not telling anybody.
So I was agitated.
And then I looked at there and I was like, I can't believe I just yelled it.
like my favorite filmmaker of all time.
他拿了最后一块披萨。不，不，有一个共同的朋友喝得有点多，表现得有点傻，他在鼓励它，你知道，玩得很开心。我说，那是非常不负责任的。现在，公平地说，我当时怀孕10周了。而且我没告诉任何人。所以我很烦躁。然后我看着那里，我想，我不敢相信我刚才喊出来了。就像我这辈子最喜欢的电影制作人。
I'm like, I'm never going to get to work with him.
I don't know what I've done.
But I was so like...
That's what it took.
And then I got Cass.
He's like, who can yell at Philip C.
Warholfman?
Who can be stern?
我当时想，我永远没机会和他合作了。我不知道我做了什么。但我当时太……那就是代价。然后我被选中了。他说，谁能对菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼（Philip C. Warholfman）大喊大叫？谁能那么严厉？
Who's that girl?
Wow.
I don't know if that's why he called me, but...
Oh, I just loved it.
He's so great.
Yeah, I still...
Anytime I hear from Paul, I'm excited.
But, yeah, he's wonderful.
那个女孩是谁？哇。我不知道他是不是因为这个才找我的，但……哦，我只是喜欢它。他太棒了。是啊，我仍然……任何时候听到保罗的消息，我都感到兴奋。但，是啊，他太棒了。
So you do that.
I mean, and then you go, and then you jump into, like,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
world, the Zach Snydery's
sort of Superman, like that whole world.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
You just have all these like different like really distinct lanes
所以你拍了那个。我的意思是，然后你去，然后你跳进了，像，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，世界，扎克·施奈德（Zach Snydery）式的超人，像整个那个世界。是啊。太棒了。你只是有所有这些不同的，非常独特的轨道
and stuff that you do totally so different.
Did you feel when you get that call?
You're like, yeah, yeah, this is something that I'm into.
No, again, I'm just super dorky and loved Superman.
So I was like, oh, I get to play Lois.
I was just, I grew up loving Superman.
Like I'm, I really, like, meant for Comic-Con like to go down there
in costume.
之类的，你做得完全不同。当你接到那个电话时，你感觉到了吗？你当时想，是啊，是啊，这是我感兴趣的东西。不，再一次，我只是超级书呆子，喜欢超人。所以我当时想，哦，我有机会演露易丝（Lois）了。我只是，我是看着超人长大的。就像我，我真的，就像为了动漫展（Comic-Con）去那里穿上戏服。
Like, that's...
Really?
Yeah, I love it.
I love jerky.
Darren's a d'or.
You've met my husband.
We're both just...
Dorky, earnest people.
就像，那是……真的吗？是啊，我喜欢。我喜欢书呆子。达伦（Darren）是个书呆子。你见过我丈夫。我们俩都只是……书呆子，认真的人。
Are you big Halloween?
Are you Halloween people?
Um, yes.
Sure, you are.
You bop around with Melissa and Ben
and you guys get all dolled up and do your thing.
That's different.
That was our movie club thing.
你们很喜欢万圣节吗？你们是万圣节那种人吗？嗯，是的。当然，你是。你和梅丽莎（Melissa）还有本（Ben）一起到处跑，你们打扮得漂漂亮亮的，做你们的事。那不一样。那是我们的电影俱乐部活动。
Right, but it's still, you guys...
Yeah, these guys, they'd watch a movie.
Yeah, oh, I do love a dress up.
I love a theme party.
I'm that girl.
Sure.
I have to, like, pull myself.
back if someone says theme party.
对，但那仍然，你们……是啊，这些家伙，他们会看电影。是啊，哦，我确实喜欢装扮。我喜欢主题派对。我就是那个女孩。当然。我不得不，像，克制自己，如果有人说主题派对。
Darren's like, Amy, you don't have to be,
you can just have a suggestion of,
but I like that.
Ugly Christmas sweater party.
Yeah, it's sign you up, right?
Yeah.
I went to a 70s birthday party a few months ago.
I already had a dress in 1970s.
达伦说，艾米，你不必，你可以只是有一个建议，但我喜欢那个。丑陋的圣诞毛衣派对。是啊，报名参加，对吧？是啊。几个月前我去了一个70年代的生日派对。我已经在1970年代有一件裙子了。
I remember that.
I was like, oh, we have to really go do it.
And then you go out kind of fun.
Yeah.
Well, luckily, Sean, you didn't have to buy a costume for that, right?
You just went into your wardrobe.
Yeah, Sean, what did you put together for that?
Yeah.
我记得那个。我当时想，哦，我们必须真的去做了。然后你出去，有点有趣。是啊。好吧，幸运的是，肖恩，你不需要为那个买戏服，对吧？你只是进了你的衣柜。是啊，肖恩，你为那个准备了什么？是啊。
I put, I think my photos.
Hot shorts?
No, I put, bell bottom pants, a big wig, you know, some gold chains and some, you know, open, yeah, Anaboa.
All right, thank you.
It's got to get dressed too?
Yeah, we both did.
Let me just pick and find the picture.
I used to get dressed up for auditions, guys.
我穿了，我想我的照片。热裤？不，我穿了，喇叭裤，一个大假发，你知道，一些金链子和一些，你知道，敞开的，是啊，羽毛围巾。好吧，谢谢。也得打扮一下？是啊，我们俩都做了。让我挑一下，找到那张照片。我以前试镜时会打扮，伙计们。
Like, I would go in costume, right?
Did you really?
Yeah, I didn't quite.
And then, like, other girls would be coming out looking absolutely beautiful.
And I would be like, oh, I guess I look like I want it too much, which is.
which is probably why I didn't work in the beginning.
I hadn't sort of cracked the code of neutrality.
I was like, it's me.
就像，我会穿戏服去，对吧？你真的吗？是啊，我没完全。然后，像，其他女孩会走出来，看起来绝对漂亮。我会想，哦，我猜我看起来像是我太想要这个角色了，这。这可能就是为什么我一开始没工作。我还没破解中立的代码。我当时想，就是我。
I don't know.
I feel like you did everything.
I have the pants.
I feel like you did everything really.
I think you did everything pretty damn well.
And then now,
your daughter doesn't,
does your daughter seem like she is attracted
我不知道。我觉得你做了一切。我有裤子。我觉得你做的一切都做得相当不错。然后现在，你女儿不，你女儿看起来她是否被吸引
to maybe going that direction too or no?
Not in performing.
And only recently,
on the set of Star Wars,
on our way to the creature shop,
she looked at me and said,
mom, do you think I could find a career in film?
Oh, wow.
去往那个方向发展，还是不？不是表演。只是最近，在《星球大战》片场，在去生物制作室的路上，她看着我说，妈妈，你觉得我能在电影业找到一份职业吗？哦，哇。
And I said, yeah, absolutely.
And did you guys start to talk about different parts of it?
Yeah.
So we're constantly talking about different.
She's like, because I love travel.
I love meeting new people.
I like every day being different.
And this is really like the best suited job for everything I want my life to look like.
我说，是啊，绝对可以。你们开始谈论它的不同部分了吗？是啊。所以我们一直在谈论不同的。她说，因为我喜欢旅行。我喜欢结识新朋友。我喜欢每天都不一样。这真的是最适合我想要的生活方式的工作。
Right.
So, yeah, so she kind of switched her motivation.
She's still like really interested in psychology, like which I love.
So she and I are constantly talking about human behavior, which is fun with a 16-year-old.
But it actually is.
She's very intuitive and insightful.
Yeah.
So we'll see.
对。所以，是啊，所以她有点改变了她的动机。她仍然像，真的对心理学感兴趣，像我喜欢的。所以她和我一直在谈论人类行为，这和16岁的孩子谈起来很有趣。但实际上确实是。她非常有直觉和洞察力。是啊。所以我们走着瞧。
So isn't it neat how the conversations change over years?
Like, you know, like as much as you might miss the toddler age, it's like, well, you couldn't really talk about, you know, global issues.
Yeah.
Now you can get their take on that.
Yeah, because they're so involved now.
Yeah. I'm right. And they get so much, and they get so much information thrown at them too.
Yeah. I want to take her over to the groundlings to take a class because she's really quick-witted and mean.
And I'm like, hey, you're great in comedy.
所以，谈话随着岁月改变不是很棒吗？就像，你知道，尽管你可能会怀念蹒跚学步的年龄，但就像，好吧，你不能真的谈论，你知道，全球问题。是啊。现在你可以得到他们对那个的看法。是啊，因为他们现在参与度很高。是啊。我说得对。而且他们也被灌输了太多的信息。是啊。我想带她去Groundlings上课，因为她真的很机智，而且刻薄。我说，嘿，你在喜剧方面很棒。
Oh, we like that. We like that.
Mean like she's not a mean person, but like her wit is so biting.
Biting and sarcastic.
My husband's like, ow. And I just think it's when she, when she nails me, I laugh so hard.
It's really funny. So.
I love it. It's fun. It's fun. It's fun.
Speaking of psychological, you've got a psychological thriller series on Apple TV.
Dude, you're so good at bringing it back, Will.
哦，我们喜欢那个。我们喜欢那个。刻薄，就像她不是一个刻薄的人，但像她的机智太尖锐了。尖锐且讽刺。我丈夫说，哎哟。我只是觉得当她，当她抓住我时，我笑得太厉害了。真的很有趣。所以。我喜欢它。很有趣。很有趣。很有趣。说到心理学，你在Apple TV上有一部心理惊悚剧。伙计，你真的很擅长把它带回来，威尔。
I know.
I appreciate that.
It's been nominated.
Thank you.
I have not been nominated.
That's a skill.
Thank you, Amy.
You've been nominated in the group.
我知道。我很感激。它被提名了。谢谢。我没被提名。那是一种技能。谢谢你，艾米。你在小组里被提名了。
In the group, group, group, Amy, this.
Sean got singled out.
Sean one time got singled out as best host interviewer.
Of a podcast.
And he's part of a threesome.
Yeah.
They single him out.
在小组，小组，小组，艾米，这个。肖恩被单独挑出来了。肖恩有一次被单独挑出来作为最佳主持人采访者。播客的。播客的。而且他是三人组的一部分。是啊。他们把他单独挑出来了。
Yeah.
He did not win.
I did not win, yeah.
Let me finish.
It's because I was held down by two others.
And I would say he's sloppy at best.
Contributive.
Oh, there they are.
是啊。他没赢。我没赢，是啊。让我说完。那是因为我被另外两个人拖累了。而且我会说他充其量是马虎。有贡献的。哦，他们在那儿。
There's a 70s.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, that's good.
I like you have hard copies, too, guys.
I know.
Scott had that.
That's beautiful.
那是70年代的。是啊，不错。哦，那很好。我喜欢你们也有硬拷贝，伙计们。我知道。我知道。斯科特（Scott）有那个。那太美了。
So let's talk about Cape Fear for a little bit.
You and Javier Bardem, I mean, sick.
What a cast, Patrick Wilson.
Yeah.
My doppel gang.
Yeah, I was going to say you sort of look like his brother.
He and I, yeah.
We've taken selfies before and posted it.
所以让我们谈谈《恐怖角》（Cape Fear）一会儿。你和哈维尔·巴登（Javier Bardem），我的意思是，太棒了。多么棒的演员阵容，帕特里克·威尔森（Patrick Wilson）。是啊。我的替身。是啊，我正想说你看起来有点像他兄弟。他和我也，是啊。我们以前拍过自拍并发布过。
Now, I was actually, I'm very cultured,
so I was watching PBS great performances last night.
And there was Patrick Wilson doing Rogers and Hammerstein.
Which one?
He's so good, you guys.
Like a medley of things along with a few other actors.
Sean, let's give us the number five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, God, there's a billion.
现在，我其实，我很有文化，所以我昨晚在看PBS的《伟大表演》（Great Performances）。帕特里克·威尔森在表演罗杰斯与汉默斯坦（Rogers and Hammerstein）。哪一个？他太棒了，伙计们。就像一首混合曲，还有其他几个演员。肖恩，给我们数字五，六，七，八。哦，天哪，有一亿个。
There's a billion.
But did you, did you, did you?
Did you and Patrick ever break out into song at all during some of the setups?
Okay.
So he's a little bit more disciplined than I am when it comes to the singing,
probably because he does it professionally,
and I do it because I just love it and it's fun.
So the first time he did sing, I thought I was being punked
有一亿个。但你，你，你？你和帕特里克在设置过程中有没有突然唱起来？好吧。所以他在唱歌方面比我更有自律，可能是因为他是专业做的，而我做是因为我只是喜欢它，而且很有趣。所以他第一次唱歌时，我以为我在被整蛊
because we were talking about some of our favorite concerts we've seen.
And I said, you know, oh, I went and saw the Indigo Girls in Red Rocks,
like 1992-93.
And it was such a good concert.
He's like, I love the Indigo Girls.
And I was like, you don't love the Indigo.
And he started singing like a deep cut from one of the albums.
And we harmonized for a bit.
因为我们在谈论我们看过的一些最喜欢的演唱会。我说，你知道，哦，我去看过Indigo Girls在红岩（Red Rocks）的演出，大概1992-93年。那是一场非常好的演唱会。他说，我喜欢Indigo Girls。我说，你不喜欢Indigo。他开始唱其中一张专辑里的一首冷门歌曲。我们和声了一会儿。
And I was like.
And singing like a songbird, right?
Guys.
Yeah.
I was like, we're going to be best friends.
We're going to have so much fun.
We like the same things.
Put your number in my phone right now.
我当时想。像百灵鸟一样唱歌，对吧？伙计们。是啊。我当时想，我们要成为最好的朋友了。我们会玩得很开心。我们喜欢同样的东西。现在就把你的号码存进我的手机。
We like the same things.
It was a lot.
But just, yeah.
I mean, all of us just talking about,
I feel like we're just, the closer we are to find,
you know what I mean?
Yes, exactly.
That's a deep cut.
我们喜欢同样的东西。那很多。但只是，是啊。我的意思是，我们所有人只是在谈论，我觉得我们只是，我们越接近发现，你知道我的意思吗？是的，没错。那是一首冷门歌曲。
But yes, Cape Fear.
Patrick's great.
Javier's great.
I mean, yeah, this one of, sick cast.
For it being so, like, challenging and difficult,
like content-wise and sort of the physicality,
it was so much fun.
And shot in Atlanta,
但是是的，《恐怖角》。帕特里克很棒。哈维尔很棒。我的意思是，是啊，这个，太棒的演员阵容。因为它如此，像，具有挑战性和困难，像内容方面和那种身体素质，它太有趣了。而且在亚特兰大拍摄，
I shot with a lot of your crew from Ozark, I believe.
Yeah, I think.
They recovered?
They were able to recover.
Amanda Marsalis, I think, directed an episode or two, yeah?
She did too, yeah.
I just worked with her.
Yeah.
我拍摄时用了你们很多《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）的剧组人员，我相信。是啊，我想。他们恢复了吗？他们能够恢复。阿曼达·马萨利斯（Amanda Marsalis），我想，导演了一两集，是吧？她也做了，是啊。我刚和她合作过。是啊。
She's lovely.
Oh, we like Amanda.
She's really nice.
I like her.
Yeah, she was great.
No, I can't wait to see that show.
I've watched the trailer a couple of times.
It looks fantastic.
她很可爱。哦，我们喜欢阿曼达。她真的很好。我喜欢她。是啊，她很棒。不，我迫不及待想看那部剧。我看了几次预告片。看起来太棒了。
It does look like a lot of night shoots, which, you know, I'd have an issue with.
You know, but there's a lot of, a lot of nights shoots.
Or is it more splits?
Yeah, maybe we can just tent.
Honestly, it was a, it was challenging.
We couldn't block.
because we had a lot of directors, so it was challenging.
We could never block shoot.
看起来确实有很多夜戏，你知道，我会有问题。你知道，但有很多，很多夜戏。还是更多的是分场拍摄？是啊，也许我们可以只是搭帐篷。老实说，这是一个，它很有挑战性。我们不能分块拍摄。因为我们有很多导演，所以很有挑战性。我们从来不能分块拍摄。
So it was a lot.
It wasn't.
So for Tracy, Jamie, explain what block shooting means.
Yeah.
Jason, you do it.
You shoot out, like if all the scenes that take place in this one particular location,
no matter what episode they're in, we're going to shoot them all in a row so that we never
所以那很多。它不是。所以对于特雷西（Tracy），杰米（Jamie），解释一下分块拍摄意味着什么。是啊。杰森，你来做。是啊。你拍出来，就像如果所有发生在这一特定地点的场景，无论它们在哪个剧集里，我们都要连续拍摄它们，这样我们就永远
have to come back to this location.
She can knock out that location.
It's cheaper for budgetary reasons.
Right, right.
Yeah, when I did sharp objects, we did a lot of.
lot of block shooting and that was nice another great project i mean yeah okay i know it's amazing your
resume you're doing okay yeah you're doing okay you're doing all right jason you are you are you are at the
tip top of what you do you're so so good and everything you've never and we've talked about there
不需要回到这个地点。她可以搞定那个地点。出于预算原因，它更便宜。对，对。是啊，当我拍《利器》（Sharp Objects）时，我们做了很多。很多分块拍摄，那很好，另一个伟大的项目，我的意思是，是啊，好吧，我知道，这太棒了，你的简历，你做得很好，是啊，你做得很好，你做得不错，杰森，你，你，你处于你所做事情的顶端，你太，太棒了，你所做的一切，你从来没有，我们谈论过那里
are very few people you're one of those people and we talk john goodman we hold up as the gold
center i always do have never a bad performance no matter what you do never a bad performance
There's still time.
No, no, Amy, you're so good, you're so talented.
Well, do you allow yourself to, this is a tough question to answer, but do you, do you have
more of her time than we're allowed, but go ahead.
Oh, shit, we are over.
Sorry.
很少有人，你是其中之一，我们谈论约翰·古德曼（John Goodman），我们把他作为黄金标准，我总是这样，从来没有糟糕的表演，无论你做什么，从来没有糟糕的表演。还有时间。不，不，艾米，你太棒了，你太有天赋了。好吧，你允许自己，这是一个很难回答的问题，但你，你拥有比我们允许的更多她的时间，但继续吧。哦，该死，我们超时了。抱歉。
You can cut a lot of my stuff out.
You guys are, no, no, no, we're going to let you go.
But do you allow yourself to sort of like say, hey, you know, I've done, I've done all right
and I'm like only halfway done.
And I thought maybe I was just going to, you know, kind of just sing and dance in front of mom and dad.
Don't say halfway.
That's because she's going to be exhausted.
No, but I mean, it's really, really impressive what you've done and what you will continue to do.
你可以剪掉我很多东西。你们是，不，不，不，我们要让你走了。但你允许自己，像，说，嘿，你知道，我做得，我做得还可以，而且我像只完成了一半。我原以为我只是会，你知道，只是在妈妈和爸爸面前唱歌跳舞。别说一半。那是因为她会精疲力竭。不，但我的意思是，你所做的和你将继续做的，真的，真的令人印象深刻。
And you're still ascendant.
And I just, it's amazing.
Well, you know, I adore you.
And I'm just grateful.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm just grateful.
I think, like, I'm 51 now.
而且你还在上升。我只是，这太棒了。好吧，你知道，我崇拜你。我只是很感激。我很感激。谢谢。我只是很感激。我想，像，我现在51岁了。
And I think being in my 50s is the greatest.
I'm so grounded and I just feel grateful and kind of open to whatever comes.
And grateful for.
what I've been able to do.
And it's a great time of reflection.
It shows.
You can, you see very comfy.
I will say, I think this is the longest I've ever talked to you because you're normally
而且我觉得50多岁是最棒的。我非常扎实，我只是感到感激，并且对任何到来的事情都持开放态度。并且感激。我能够做到的事情。这是一个反思的好时机。这显示出来了。你可以，你看上去很舒服。我会说，我想这是我跟你谈话时间最长的一次，因为你通常
ducking out of parties.
I know.
Oh, wow.
That doesn't sound like you.
So I'm so excited to get to talk to you.
It's something both these boys know, you know.
Yeah.
I go out and then it's time to go home.
在派对上溜走。我知道。哦，哇。那听起来不像你。所以我很高兴能和你谈话。这是这两个男孩都知道的事情，你知道。是啊。我出去，然后是时候回家了。
No, you're smart.
Yeah, it's time to get into bed.
Like Jay always says, there's a window of energy.
And once that energy's up, that's it.
That's smart.
Well, I'm an introvert.
and also I don't drink anymore.
And so it's usually the last two hours at the party,
不，你很聪明。是啊，是时候上床睡觉了。就像杰伊（Jay）总是说的，有一个能量窗口。一旦那个能量用完了，就是这样。那很聪明。好吧，我是个内向的人。而且我也不再喝酒了。所以通常是派对的最后两个小时，
you've got to have a little in you.
Otherwise, the stuff that's being talked about
is just not that interesting.
Yeah.
And the stuff ain't that funny.
I'm usually the last person they are talking about that.
Not interesting.
That's like I know.
你得有一点在里面。否则，谈论的事情就没那么有趣了。是啊。而且事情也没那么好笑。我通常是他们谈论的最后一个人。不有趣。那就像我知道。
Can I top that out for you?
No, no, no.
Anymore, I'll be leaving at the same time.
I'm too tired.
I'm just tired.
Word to the wise,
if you run into Jason in a social setting,
Just make sure you have a bunch of stuff loaded
我能为你顶替那个吗？不，不，不。不再了，我会同时离开。我太累了。我只是累了。给智者的话，如果你在社交场合遇到杰森，只要确保你装载了一堆东西
just to try to keep him interested
because he doesn't want to talk to you.
Sounds like a really great guy, doesn't he?
It's not true.
Self-involved asshole.
Jesus Christ, sometimes you do it for other people,
not just for you, you fucking dick.
God, you've had so much given to you.
只是为了试着让他感兴趣，因为他不想和你说话。听起来是个很棒的家伙，不是吗？那不是真的。自我参与的混蛋。耶稣基督，有时你为别人做，不仅仅为你自己，你这个该死的混蛋。上帝，你被给予了这么多。
You've had so much attention and shit given to your whole life.
Why don't you fucking give back to other people?
No bless oblige.
All right.
Let's ask some questions.
Amy Adams.
What a pleasure.
You're just a delight.
你一生中被给予了这么多关注和狗屎。你为什么不该死地回馈给别人？不，贵族义务。好吧。让我们问一些问题。艾米·亚当斯。真是荣幸。你真是个快乐。
We love you.
You're so great.
And thank you so much.
We can't wait for Cape Fear on Apple TV.
It's fantastic.
And we just continued success.
You're just the great.
Thanks, guys.
我们爱你。你太棒了。非常感谢。我们迫不及待想看Apple TV上的《恐怖角》。它太棒了。我们只是继续成功。你真是太棒了。谢谢，伙计们。
Thanks for having me on.
I can talk to you guys for hours.
Likewise.
Hugs and kisses to Darren.
Yeah, to Amanda and the girls as well.
Thank you, honey.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, bye.
谢谢邀请我。我可以和你们聊几个小时。同样。拥抱和亲吻达伦。是啊，也给阿曼达和女孩们。谢谢，亲爱的。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。再见。
Bye.
Double A, right there.
I'm married to a AA.
Mandata, yeah, Amy Adams.
Yeah, that's right.
Two A's, two A's, two A's, two A's, double A.
And she's, what a career.
Every single thing you guys remember, I'm like, oh, that's right.
再见。双A，就在那儿。我嫁给了一个双A。Mandata，对，艾米·亚当斯。没错，就是这样。两个A，两个A，两个A，两个A，双A。而且她，职业生涯真是太棒了。你们记得的每一件事，我都觉得，哦，没错。
Oh, that's right. Oh, my God, that's right.
I mean, everything's quality.
Everything's quality.
Always.
And even if it's not, she's the best thing in it.
I mean, it's just, it never sucks.
No, that's what, that's a very, that's a rare, rare error.
Yeah, we all clank it every once in a while, but I don't, I think she's either buried the things that
哦，没错。天哪，没错。我是说，每一部作品都是精品。每一部都是精品。一直如此。即使不是，她也是其中最棒的部分。我是说，这简直，从来不会烂。不，那是，那是一个非常，非常罕见的错误。是的，我们偶尔都会搞砸，但我认为她要么是把那些她表现不好的作品埋葬了，要么就是她从来没演过烂片。
she hasn't been good in or she's just never been bad.
Remember a night bitch?
Did you guys see night bitch?
I never saw it.
I saw the trailer
and I thought that
looks cool.
I like that moment
她表现不好的作品，或者她从来没演过烂片。还记得《夜行悍妇》吗？你们看过《夜行悍妇》吗？我没看过。我看了预告片，觉得看起来很酷。我喜欢那个时刻
just looking at
I'm just pulled up
all of her stuff
because I'm like
I can't believe
it's awesome
Oh when you look at her
things
我刚才查了她所有的作品，因为我觉得简直太不可思议了，太棒了。哦，当你查看她的作品时
It's amazing
I was going to ask
what
musical she was in
she was into the woods
and in a 2013 interview magazine piece
she said she watched
Bye Bye Birdie with her dad
太惊人了。我本来想问她演过什么音乐剧，她演过《魔法黑森林》，在2013年的一篇《采访》杂志文章中，她说她和她爸爸一起看过《再见小鸟迪》
who's a huge
Ann Margaret fan
but she's never done that show
but it's a great title
Oh yeah
I was going to say, I'm surprised you didn't use bye-bye birdie for the goodbye,
but it sounds like you might be doubling back on that.
Well, it's one of those things.
她爸爸是安·玛格丽特的超级粉丝，但她从来没演过那部剧，不过那是个很棒的标题。哦，是的，我本来想说，我很惊讶你没有用《再见小鸟迪》来作为告别，但听起来你可能会回过头来用它。嗯，这是那种情况之一。
Look, you know what?
He didn't, but everything happens for Eresas, you know?
You see?
Told you.
Well, there's a re-up coming Will's way.
You mean a Rees up.
You got it.
So if you haven't already, get out and bye!
听着，你知道吗？他没用，但一切皆有缘分，你知道吗？你看？我告诉过你。好吧，威尔即将迎来一次重聚。你是说瑞茜（Reese）的重聚。你说对了。所以如果你还没行动，赶紧去买吧！
Bye!
So, Rees!
Smart.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by
Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.
再见！所以，瑞茜！Smartless是由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf 100%有机且手工制作的。Smartless。